ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
friends fans members I am Seamus
Coughlin filling in for Tim Poole who
said he had a quote tummy ache this
morning and didn't want to quote come
into podcasting today I'm excited for
tonight's show we have a wonderful guest
we also have a number of very
interesting stories here Trump has
announced that he fears he is going to
be arrested for his supposed involvement
in January 6th Iowa is in the middle of
a legal battle over abortion uh and
euthanasia activists in the Netherlands
has been convicted of sending over 1600
suicide kits to different people across
the country all that and more tonight
but first before we get into it I want
to ask you all to smash that like button
and become members at timcast.com if you
do you will not only be supporting the
show and the Empire that we're
attempting to build here but you'll also
get access to the after show segments
where things get a little spicy we don't
have to follow the sort of conventional
YouTube or television rules and it gets
a little bit wild it's kind of a
free-for-all I think you guys would like
to check that out after the show it's
it's usually pretty engaging I'll also
ask all of you to go over to
castbrew.com pick yourself up a bag of
cast Brew Coffee we're our own sponsor
we are building culture and you know
what it's never tasted so good cast Brew
absolutely delicious I want all of you
to go check that out order a bag help us
out with what we're doing here tonight
we are joined by Connor Thomason of the
Lotus Eaters thank you so much for
coming in thank you very much for
inviting me everyone yes uh Connor
Tomlinson writer and host over at
loadsetas.com spearheaded by the
wonderful Carl Benjamin also frequent
face on GB news the English equivalent
to Fox essentially you might want to
come up come up on the mic a little I'll
move that closer there where you can
move it around with you too fantastic
thank you very much and uh yeah
generally just just talk a lot of
rubbish for a living so nice hey well
you're in good company
joined by the rest of us that's all we
do that's all we do yeah that's all we
do professionally and in our spare time
yep it's uh 24 7 here uh I'm Hannah
Claire brimlow I'm a writer from
timcast.com I'm so glad that you're
joining us tonight and I think it'll be
a fun show I'm Ian Crossland I did
triceps and shoulders today nice
hardcore baby it balanced out the biceps
and I guess uh something else I did
yesterday uh I feel great I I feel uh
hot and I did Stitch and Adam's podcast
earlier today yeah how was that it was
awesome those guys are all fantastic
yeah I like them uh so you can find that
at Stitch and Adam on YouTube check it
out after the show after the after show
after coming to visit us at timcast.com
I'm gonna pass it over to Serge Dupree
hey guys what's going on uh some stuff
got changed in the settings last night
so it sounded weird let me know in the
chat uh but we'll be good um surge.com
again on Twitter Etc follow me argue
with me take it away Seamus all right
getting into our first story tonight
Donald Trump uh fears that he is going
to be charged in connection with the
January 6th riot at the Capitol uh he
released a statement on Truth social
where he said he was anticipating that
he'd be investigated we have a quote uh
from him here deranged Jack Smith the
prosecutor with uh President Joe Biden's
doj sent a letter again it was Sunday
night stating that I am a target of the
January 6th grand jury investigation and
giving me a very short four days to
respond to the grand jury which almost
always means an arrest and indictment so
that's a massive uh the former host of
this show sir Timothy cast often has a
two-word phrase that he references
especially in reference to the president
of the United States having legal
pressure on him or a former president
being arrested you all know what that
phrase is I don't have any drink to
hands
yeah no no no Civil War that is what he
would say and in honor of him I must
repeat those words because it's what he
would have wanted how do you guys feel
about this and also as a Brit looking
and seeing American culture and Society
in governmental operations how does this
look to you uh well we as an American
vassal State a relationship which should
have never been inverted but but there
you go
to the chat already
um it's obviously political indictment
it's obvious that they're trying to just
get him off of the ballot in whichever
states which would bar him if he if he
were indicted from from being off
because they're petrified of him winning
a safe and secure election
um one of the most egregious ones that
we covered on our show was the E Gene
Carroll case where and we can't say she
was making it up because that would be
liberalous but considering she might
have gotten her story from a Law and
Order episode this does not look very
credulous
um also the the whole documents thing I
mean yeah okay he's probably stored them
improperly judging by the photos that
were given to the New York Post but he
does have declassification power Joe
Biden does the same thing obviously a
partisan justice system and so this is
just another attempt in a long line of
incredulous claims to to try and scare
him off and frankly as a Brit
um I don't think our political
establishment would like Donald Trump
back in I mean the then home secretary
said to jabard wrote uh piece for the
time saying that he publicly endorsed
Joe Biden while still in government
um things like that just ridiculous but
but Trump's energy policy for example
fantastic for the UK before we decided
to blow all our money on Ukraine and
demolish our energy security because and
this was one of my former jobs I used to
work in energy policy and Trump from
2017 to 2019 made America not only the
First Energy independent for the first
time since Nixon signed the Mandate with
with expanding fracking getting natural
gas but you guys despite Donald Trump
being a climate denier
um he made the US lead the world in
reducing their emissions and so you're
achieving environmental goals whilst
also making it so that you're insulated
from geopolitical conflict yeah of
course the uh the uniparty types that
wanted to sell all of your strategic
reserves to sign a peck couldn't have
that and and so if Trump were back the
UK would would be absolutely benefiting
but um yeah they're doing their best not
to I think a lot of us would be
benefiting from it one thing I find
fascinating you mentioned climate change
the fact that Trump is a climate denier
this is one of the most ridiculous
phrases that you hear thrown around
politically a person can be totally
accepting of every single thing that's
even supposedly in the scientific
consensus surrounding climate change but
if they're not an alarmist who says the
world is going to end in 12 years and
then says that again in 12 years when
the prophecy doesn't come true then
there are total climates in Iron we have
to disregard everything they say there's
a sleight of hand that frequently occurs
with say something like 97 of climate
scientists agree that humans are having
some effect on global temperatures or
climate and they will use that to
suggest that 97 of climate scientists
say that we have catastrophic climate
change that is going to kill us in 10
years if we don't pass the green new
deal it's it's ridiculous but it's also
interesting to get back to the topic
after I've pontificated on that to just
consider the way Trump is viewed uh in
Europe and I'm curious what the view of
the average English person is it doesn't
surprise me that your establishment
doesn't like him because he's a very
anti-establishment but like on the
ground when you're dealing with everyday
average people what's the general
feeling about him and also is this kind
of thing talked about the legal scandals
here uh January 6th whether it was an
Insurrection Etc uh there talks about
peripherally it depends on if a person
watches mainstream news or not if they
watch the BBC just because and and I
don't wish to disparage my own mother
she's lovely and she supports my career
but if you're turning on the TV and you
go on autopilot you might see the the 60
second News Bulletin that says president
Trump has been indicted again or or the
January 6th committee has declared him
guilty or whatever
um lots of people will find his right
rhetoric bombastic just because of
British manners um it's kind of out fair
enough outside of our Norm but I think
like pretty much all rhetoric is
bombastic compared to British manners
now well it's sort of actually to be
fair I've seen lots of Americans really
enjoy our House of Commons debates
because we we do they're amazing
deliberately insult each other at this
batch box though it's still bread and
circuses because they both agree on the
same policies at all times like if you
examine the conservative and labor
parties like it's the Michael malice
phrase conservatism is progressivism
driving the speed limit well you know
both parties just flooring it right now
but uh but not to wander off topic um
lots of the British public
I think lots of them like Trump's
character just because he's kind of
funny and how it sticks to the
establishment in the same way that they
liked Nigel farage and brexit like Nigel
farage got about four million votes the
last time he ran and didn't get a seat
because of our electoral system but lots
of the British public was so fed up with
the uh capital P Progressive
unidirectional narrative that Tony Blair
in the 1990s said was as inevitable as
the changing of the seasons that they
really just wanted to stick at The
Establishment and this is why they voted
Boris eventually in 2019. Unfortunately
they didn't pan out very well because he
ended up being a progressive as well but
he won a stonking majority because
people thought he was a bit like a
British Trump you know a sort of
foul-mouthed guy who was dragged
backwards he'd be on their side um and
so the perception of trump is basically
if you watch the mainstream news you're
not gonna like him because you think
he's rude and bombastic any of the first
democracy if not you're going to think
of him similar to brexit of these people
aren't acting in my interests and I will
take a stick of dynamite to tear it all
asunder
um than another sort of polite nodding
establishment figure like a Mitt Romney
or something um
I think so many Americans feel sort of
similarly they actually like Trump's
energy it is appealing to them he is a
pressure fresh air the that's why these
campaigns to get him indicted on
literally anything to have the headline
always be Trump charged Trump
investigated Trump you know whatever to
make him look bad is so important
because so much of the public and I'm
sure it's true across the ocean just
read the headline right they'll never go
into the details of what's being said
they just want to string enough words
together to scare you away from
inquiring further and that's sort of
what's toxic about our news cycle uh you
know one of the most powerful moments of
the campaign this year for me has been
uh Trump on stage at Town Hall refuting
everything that was brought against him
was the eating Carol Case and it was
hilarious I mean beautiful median it's
so that's funny and also calm and
logical and it's not you know this
terrible
ugly speech it's just like I own the
plaza across the street why would any of
this have happened and well that's
exactly right and so here's one of the
things about Donald Trump that I think
is often overlooked and one of the
probably most unfair characterizations
you'll see of him of course he's going
to be compared to a fascist because they
compare everyone they don't like to a
fascist but his speeches are the most
anti-fascistic style speeches you're
ever going to hear a fascist leader gets
up in front of the people he's extremely
serious he's extremely strong it's not
time for joking around it's time for
business Trump just goes up there and he
riffs and he's hilarious and everyone
has a great time and part of what was so
beautiful about that CNN Town Hall was
the fact that this woman was speaking to
him in literally positioning herself as
the anti-fun person this is a CNN Town
Hall this audience was not selected
because they loved Donald Trump and even
they were cracking up and having a great
time because of his delivery and his
performance now you can sit there and
say I don't want that in a leader I
don't want someone who cracks jokes I
don't want someone who has that kind of
Charisma sure whatever that's not what
I'm trying to address here but my point
is the media will play clips of him and
then criticize those and even then they
don't end up looking that great
attempting to criticize him in person on
stage when the people in the audience
are on his side is the worst possible
Optics because everyone's having a great
time and laughing and CNN is there going
no stop stop having fun you need to stop
having fun stop having fun right now and
they ended up cutting it early because
of that Caitlin Collins is that you're
talking about I believe so that's she's
an interesting person and I don't want
to I don't want to add homonym on that
girl too much because but I've just
noticed I'm not I'm not ad homing her
I'm just saying yeah I'm about to so I'm
just saying beforehand I don't want to
but I'm going to I like her but I mean I
like that what she's doing I'm glad
she's out there but like her smile she's
got like I don't know if she got work
done on her face but the sides of her
mouth are like up in a smile but
everything about her face shows misery
doesn't smile behind the eyes yeah
there's lots of people like that in
media yeah um it's a sort of I I don't
want to psychoanalyze or step outside My
remix Telltale sign a psychopathy yeah I
was I was just gonna say that I'm not
going to speak to her condition
specifically but that that is something
you'll notice there's amazing exactly
and that's why it makes sense that there
are so many people in the media who have
that kind of face that and that is
Hillary Clinton's face right I mean
she's very much got that phony smile and
this is something about Donald Trump
that a lot of people
appreciate I think even people who don't
agree with him policy wise uh will
usually acknowledge is a good thing
somebody like Hillary Clinton right
she's a person who follows every single
one of the rules and conventions
necessary to create good optics for
oneself and be considered a conventional
political leader who could be tenable to
the American people and the
establishment but behind closed doors
and behind the scenes we all know she's
unbearably corrupt Donald Trump on the
other hand follows none of the rules
none of the social conventions
surrounding the way political leaders
are supposed to speak and act in this
country and yet relative to basically
every establishment political leader in
this country and especially Hillary
Clinton he's squeaky clean this is not
something I would have said about him
back in 2016 by the way I wouldn't vouch
for the guy at that time when the Russia
stuff first came up I was unsure if it
was true or not but as they continue to
investigate and it continued to become
apparent that it was a nothing burger
and they'd spent years trying to nail
him on anything they could with all of
these random investigations and they
found nothing it became obvious that
this guy was way cleaner than I ever
thought he was to begin with if I can
just pick up on two things there um the
first thing is how he presents himself
optically is I don't want to say it's a
tactic but it's something I've learned
that's very useful for when you do
mainstream television because it's very
different to the sort of relaxed
long-form stuff that you guys do here
and we do over at loader seaters and
that is most of the time people just
want to monologue in their little
section box and they want to say their
piece and they're not actually
addressing you if you're on a debate
panel with someone they're just trying
to win the audience over what Trump does
is he breaks the fourth wall he shows
that the emperor has no clothes he
routinely says okay this is how they're
framing something this is how they're
trying to make me look bad when I've
done that on air before if someone isn't
addressing my point I'll just say to the
audience oh um just just so you guys
know you're not gonna answer my question
that's it just so everyone can see
you're just going to dodge it and you're
going to come up with your prescriptive
talking points and it shows the
disingenuity of the establishment and
that connects to the fact of and this is
why they say certain things are Beyond
debate or they say something's a threat
to democracy or the unit party agrees on
both policies there's a German legal
theorist I know James Lindsay is not a
fan of um as he has had a goat me on
Twitter this week uh Carl Schmidt um now
let me declare I disavow his mid-century
German allegiances later on but before
he joined the party that we will not
name
um he recognized that things like
liberalism and Technology are
de-politicizing forces and he defined
political as the friend enemy
distinction there is a group of people
that are against your your end stated
goals and there are a group of people
that are for it and even though you
might have a common Enemy at the time
when the enemy is vanquished are we
rebuilding the same society and the
depoliticizing force it eliminates
admires things in debate and it it says
certain things are Beyond debate and so
it stigmatizes certain perspectives and
actually that smuggles in the
existential threat so that would be like
the fall of the Republic so the wheels
are still spinning the oligarchs are
still profiting and in the background
the forces of entropy are setting on
your country and tearing it apart and
that's what I think people felt when
they voted for Donald Trump they felt
that the establishment had ring fenced
off certain things like like the the
global offshoring of manufacturing to
leave the country behind the hollowing
out of the social texture of the United
States where we're all just squabbling
over equality and forgetting about the
capital c Creator and the Bill of Rights
and because those things were Beyond
reproach it didn't not have human
consequences and they saw this man as a
re-politicizing force they're going to
speak to us his friends against our
enemies he is pointing out the
depoliticizing framing and he's
hammering them on it yeah I think social
media censorship was also a techno
technological uh I don't know squishing
of you know civil rights or at least
like who who has the right to tell me I
can't say what I want on the internet
just because it's uh owned by a private
company like no no no it's it's I agree
with you the technology is Way Beyond
politics and it and it can take things
like like a snowball down a hill so for
good or evil I understand where you're
for good or bad like whether or not it's
good that we had someone come in and
start saying he's a bad guy he's a bad
guy I'm a good guy like it is polarizing
but it's maybe people just craved it
subconsciously because we've been in
this like bubble of like allowing the
these corporations to kind of take
control yeah well no I I think there's
some truth in that and also say I think
the primary reason why people want this
friend enemy distinction is because in
reality you do have friends and you do
have enemies and there is such a thing
as good and evil and for a very long
time what evil has done is attempted to
blur the lines between the two so that
it could ultimately redefine them
there's no such thing as good there's no
such thing as bad it's all one thing and
then once people are confused enough
they start to tell you that the good
things are bad and the bad things are
good and speaking of that abortion is
once again legal in Iowa just two days
after an abortion ban at six weeks was
signed into law a judge has just struck
down these restrictions and I really
should call them protections because
they're protections of The Unborn and
abortion is now legal up to 20 weeks in
Iowa yeah Iowa's a really interesting
case because you're seeing this live
battle play out I mean when Governor Kim
Reynolds went to sign this new
legislation which successfully passed
the Republican held house after a
special session
there was a judge saying you know I am
actively in the middle of a challenge on
this and I can't it would be flippant of
me to rule on this without giving it
consideration so that law went into
effect on Friday and he came out early
this week and said you know actually we
can't go forward with this we're going
to revert back to our 20-week ban on
abortion uh Kim the legislation in
question is a six-week ban there are
certain exceptions for uh rape incest uh
fetal viability if it's in question or
if it's it they couldn't survive outside
the womb and mother's health what I find
interesting is you're seeing Iowa itself
split apart and of course for us I was
significant because it's an early
primary State uh what happens in Iowa
especially during elections cycle is
often viewed as a magnifying glass on
the rest of the country yeah no I agree
and I think we're going to see a lot
more of this there's going to be a
massive Clash there I'm curious to hear
your perspective on this once again and
as is somebody coming over here from
England what are the laws and social
conventions like surrounding abortion
one thing you hear all the time from
American progressives is that we are
just this backwards far-right Theocratic
Nation relative to the enlightened
Europeans who just let anything that the
progressives want happen but especially
prior to row if you actually looked at
abortion laws in Europe you would find
that many of them were actually more
strict than the laws that you would have
especially in blue states in the U.S
I am sorry to rain on your parade a
little bit
um that's not the case in how it plays
out in England so in oh no the English
case is legally it's 24 weeks to spot
other than if you can have a health
example that can justify it going
further and can I just interject us one
question yes when you say health example
so in the United States like like for
example there are certain blue states
where like up until the point of birth
which is why I'm saying that it that's
so much harsher than what you have in
Europe but what I want to ask you about
with this legal exception for the case
of the life of the mother one thing that
happens in the U.S is they will use
things like depression or a poor mental
health outcome to justify that is it the
same it's exactly the same in England
yeah that we we have far fewer abortions
in the United States
um as a proportion of population as well
but it still does happen and abortion in
the UK is unfortunately one of those
things that's just declared Beyond
reproach I was once once called um
anti-enlish because I was against
abortion because it's just been settled
law for for how long anti-english huh
yeah and I want English babies aborted
yeah I know yeah radical position I
suppose
um one of the disturbing things that's
happened and this has happened
um both because of the rising prominence
in the polls of the labor party after
their stinking defeat in 2019 they're
now getting a bit more bold because they
know they're probably going to win the
next election anyway and after the
unaids principles which I don't know if
you guys know about no okay I'll explain
that in a minute because it's a pretty
dark Rabbit Hole um but we recently had
a debate in Parliament um among the MPS
this isn't tabled legislation yet but
about a right to an abortion in a
British Bill of Rights that is being
drafted after brexit and Stella Creasy
who is a labor MP she sits on the
women's Council she had gone from I
think it was two years ago bringing her
infant into the House of Commons even
though they have daycare which I'm
against
um but she could have put it in the
crash in time she made a deliberate
point to bring the baby in went from
that to arguing to no restrictions on
abortion and a right to abortion
codified within the British Bill of
Rights in law and so they're getting
pretty bold for that um and one of the
reasons I think this is the case is
because the UN on International women's
day this March put out their 21 AIDS
principles to govern
um Sexual Health Drug law things like
that and among these things were
um abortion up until the point of birth
has absolutely no restrictions for all
member states
um Downstream from that it was the
decriminalization of all drugs including
uh who was the fellow from launch from
was it launched from the Surfs yeah yeah
um that's the un's position now you
should be able to take drugs and suffer
no penalties while you're pregnant
um all gender affirming care for all
ages and they also said that there are
some cases where children may be mature
enough to consent disgusting yes and
disgusting yeah and and so this is
something that is coming for most
countries probably in Europe as well
um that's the case in the UK how does
British law work like uh if you're
talking about like York Northumberland
do they have their own sets of Rights
like state rights no no no it's all
centralized it's it's just Nationals is
that also like federal police everywhere
like yeah yeah so we have we have the
Met police in London um who operate from
a slight different commissioner I think
each each area has Commissioners but we
can like Central to the government they
can set General policing law the police
in England are mad as well I nearly got
arrested last year outside conservative
to Party Conference there was a video
that did did the rounds what ended up
happening was
um I went outside to film a Street
Preacher who was arguing with some young
girls who were arguing in favor of
abortion just outside the secure Zone
and I was filming it and a local
journalist came up to me and said what
do you think of this and I've just
arrived on scene what's even happening
and she said this gentleman here is
saying that the lgbtq plus Community are
unnatural according to scripture and I
said right well I haven't heard any of
this but you know I've just been
speaking to the LGB Alliance guys and
they separate sexuality and gender so
that's part of the debate you have to
parcel out and the TQ plus might be
harbinging something more Insidious and
I said have you heard of Gail Rubin and
before I finished my thought an
inspector who had been bused in from
from Kent to Birmingham which is you
know cancer South Birmingham to North
that's where the conference was run up
to me waved his finger in my face um he
had to go on his tiptoes because he's
rather short and he said to me right
um if you continue this conversation on
warning you I will arrest you under the
public order offense bill because you've
insulted This Woman's sexuality because
he'd overheard the word Insidious not
overheard the conversation properly and
he just said do you understand what I'm
saying and when I try to clarify and ask
my questions he said this is not about
questioning I'm telling you what's
happening here I got surrounded by 10
other police officers arms folded
riddled to tackle me and one guy had a
shoulder mounted camera recording the
entire thing and what they do in the UK
is if you are reported for like an
offense but it's not criminal offense
you'll be registered on the non-crime
hate incident registry which means
there's a black mark against your name
that you never know exists and if
employers do a background check on you
even if you've been criminally charged
that will come up and you will be turned
down for jobs without ever knowing it so
I I had to rely on some a lovely
gentleman by the name of Harry Miller
he's worked for fair cop now
um bad law project and he he got
confirmation that I wasn't in that
registry we filed a complaint to the
police but it went nowhere because they
protect their own and so yeah England's
England's undoubtedly a very uh
Progressive captured country can I ask
you do you feel like there's a cultural
difference in the different regions like
Northern England has a different
attitude towards these things than maybe
the South because that's what I feel is
at least The Stereotype in America that
we're very regionally divided uh you'll
hear West Coast versus you know
conservative Texas perhaps uh we have
something called the red wall in England
and that was created because when
Margaret Thatcher was in power she
decided to disband in industries that
she thought were defunct mainly things
like coal mining and they had been
long-standing sources of community
wealth since generational prosperity for
years even though they weren't
generating as much and when she ripped
that out um she did a lot of battle with
the unions as well and so that's that's
made them more union-ish and so they
voted labor as as a part of their
identity she didn't really replace it
with anything and so up north
um you know there's a north-south
antagonism they they we call them
Northern monkeys they call us Southern
pufters and we we get along with a bit
of a bit of solidarity against against
any other country that wants to try
their luck
um but they have resentment of the South
house because they see politics too
centralized in the South and they see it
as they left them behind and this was
the big difference of Boris Johnson 2019
as well because the north overwhelmingly
voted for brexit thinking that we're
sending too much money over to the
European Union it could be reinvested
here and Boris Johnson said right if you
guys let me Evo I'll do that I'll do a
program called leveling up which
basically means you'll get new rail
infrastructure you get new job
opportunities with the regional
investment and the Northerners voted for
him and then they voted obviously for
Boris because they they liked him on
character you know he used to be the
London mayor he got stuck on a zip line
he'd wave little Flags he was like Mr
Bean you know people people thought it
was fun um then covert hit lockdowns
happened we were imprisoned in our home
for multiple years and Boris who
professed to be a Libertarian squandered
all the money away on that and then
started partying while we were all
locked in our homes and that all got
leaked and it was a big yeah I've heard
about this the the league of political
leaders partying in England what is the
Fallout from that ban uh Boris Johnson
got scapegoated from it Matt Hancock who
was the health secretary who was having
an affair with one of his aides at the
time CCTV
um he lost his job but he really needed
a Social distance well yeah I mean um if
you if anyone ever sees a photo of Matt
Hancock I I feel deeply ashamed because
he was doing better with his love life
under lockdown than I do and he is not a
good looking bloke
um but he hasn't lost his place in the
party like Boris Johnson's basically
just been kicked out the commons his
seat is up for re-election um on the GB
News host Lawrence Fox is currently
running in that so I wish him luck but
he really was the scapegoat I mean they
said everything was his fault and I feel
like from my observational standpoint
the party sort of let him uh pay for
their sins yeah take the fall yeah and
and all of the health Executives that
got all the calls around got knighthoods
um Gavin Williamson he was the education
secretary who repeatedly locked down
schools but despite being campaigned not
to
um he resigned from his post for a
particular reason that doesn't come to
mind right now but he resigned in
disgrace and then got a Knighthood from
it it's like they're just buying
people's silence what's the what's the
neighborhood do uh it's just a title
which confers upon you the sort of you
have been endorsed by this do you get
money for it or anything are you really
stipend no no I don't think can you like
kick people off of their land or any of
that crap no I don't think you get any
titles but it's based
Boris kept trying to appoint his dad a
member of the House of Lords repeatedly
and remember she didn't shut that down
but but that's absolutely to your point
Rishi sunak is the prime minister right
now he wasn't elected like the when
Boris went the members chose Liz trust
now Liz truss is dim as a two what bulb
she's she's not great but she was too
dumb to be on side of the global project
what we have is a bit of split in the
conservative party right now with the
neocons they both share goals on Ukraine
but for different reasons um the neocons
are more Cold War the global faction are
more like we want to line blackrock's
Pockets um Liz truss was filming the
neocon camp and she wanted to majorly
well not majorly minorly cut taxes right
British and that was a tax and spend guy
um he was the guy that printed all the
money as Chancellor during covid he did
he did the equivalent to stimulus
packages let's bankrupted the country um
but they spun the narrative as to where
it's only Ukraine and the pandemic it
wasn't what she soon next for the
members voted for this truss
overwhelmingly Liz Tross gets in and
she's the shortest serving prime
minister in history because she wanted
to do what a one percent tax car and she
announced it on a Monday the bank of
England uh the the published that sort
of stats on the guilt Market on the
Friday and the News didn't hit till the
Monday and it coincided with the fact
the bank of England realized they'd run
out of money so they useless trust his
policy as a scapego and we know this
because like Rishi Seneca immediately
started spending more money and this
suddenly wasn't going to break the
market how weird and so they got their
man in they got them in by the back door
despite him being utterly compressor in
in the parties and the economic damage
done under the pandemic and so
unfortunately the British political
systems kind of just wreaked but you
said that you think he'll get elected
you think the British public has
embraced him as well no no lose he'll
lose it absolutely
Uma the labor party but the interesting
thing and Matt Goodwin is a really good
academic from my former University who's
looked at this uh six in ten of people
that voted for Boris that includes those
red wall people who traditionally voted
labor flipped to conservative they feel
so disenfranchised they're just not
voting because for the last 15 years
we've voted consistently for lowered
immigration last year under Boris
Johnson it hit net 1.1 million plus
illegals and the rate at which the
illegal immigration is going up by 2024
we're going to have more people crossing
the channel and filling up UK hotels
than British men stormed the beaches of
Normandy at D-Day my goodness so yeah
this is bad
um they've had all their promises broken
and so they've just decided right we're
not flipping our votes there's no
Alternatives so we're just not voting
and so labor are going to win by default
even though they've been utterly
incompetent yeah so so one thing I'd
also like to ask you about is you know I
can't imagine the British media is too
different from American Media with
respect to the way the Border issue is
addressed or really not addressed right
the question is always of Are We being
nice enough to people who entered our
country illegally and not should we have
borders so I'm curious what some of the
rhetoric surrounding that has been
differences similarities or if it's just
kind of the same garbage that we get
here it's similar you'd think it would
be different because we're an island so
naturally we don't have any connecting
borders with countries
um it's often about Our obligation to
take in quote-unquote refugees but all
of the people coming across are coming
from France now I'd France too you know
it's horrible
um but loads of loads of the so-called
economic migrants I mean for quite a
while last year it was all albanians now
Albania is not a country at War uh they
voted in the socialist government so
economic downturn is is there but they
were being trafficked by people
smuggling gangs and then they had an
Albania Day celebration where they drove
very flash cars around Parliament square
and direct Winston Churchill's flag
statue in the Albanian flag so it was
almost like a uh yeah despite
colonialism exactly um so they've broken
a deal recently the Albanian governments
they've stopped coming we're still
getting loads of people from the migrant
camps in Calais from Afghanistan and
North Africa and and things like that
and lots of the conversation this is
mainly the labor party's policy it's
gonna be
um how do we create safe and legal
routes for these people it's never they
shouldn't be here in the first place
because they don't have a legitimate
Asylum claim it's like right how do we
take them out from the hotels which
we're paying seven million pounds a day
to put them up in and these are hotels
that people would go to work to pay to
stay in on holiday how do we move from
that to just dropping them in the
economy because we want you GDP line go
up that's it yeah well speaking of
illegal border crossings a U.S soldier
crossed into North Korea willfully and
without authorization so uh United
States soldier was in custody actually
uh in South Korea in a prison he'd been
held on assault charges and was facing
additional military discipline and he
was escorted to the airport but instead
of getting on his flight he basically
ran away he joined a tour group with a
group of civilians who were going near
the border he escaped that tour group he
ran into North Korea and of course this
creates a massive diplomatic problem you
know the United States and North Korea
are not in contact with one another but
of course the United States government
is going to want to get this guy back
what could he have done that was so bad
that he thought he would be better off
in North Korea maybe he thought Every
Woman looked like yomi Park and he
thought he'd take his chances is it
something like that I just I can't
imagine I mean it's wild it's it's
insanely dangerous guy must not have
been thinking was he drunk what's going
on and I wonder now if he's twenty is
going to be like it's great that you're
here just tell us about your job oh for
sure let's hear what's going on you know
they are being very mean to you that
American Military we we don't like that
at all actually Ian just raised a
perfect Point early 20s I do think that
might factor in because there's a lot of
danger tourism like one of the guys that
we work with in lowercase office Callum
um went over to Afghanistan so just not
doing his head uh he went over with Lord
miles and I don't know if anyone knows
but uh there was an update from the
Taliban today of Lord miles is still
being very politely very securely very
friendly held by the by the Taliban um
yeah so this might be a sort of danger
tourism thing of where he's going well
this looks like a crazy Place nobody's
been to maybe I'll try my luck I mean to
that to that end uh we should point out
that Otto one beer was the last uh high
profile at least he's not the the most
recent Americans have gone over but uh
he was a college student he had gone
over because he wanted to see the world
he wanted to be interesting and
apparently he stole a poster and got
held for years and years and ended up
dying that's right shortly after Trump
negotiated his return I think that he
said he someone in his church group
claimed that if he brought something
back that they would give him a car or
something wild like that and yeah so the
dude was sentenced to 10 years hard
labor if I'm not mistaken that might not
have been exactly but he ended up dying
before we could get him back yeah they
said it was botulism that killed him but
then there are reports actually there
was a North Korean defected spy defect
that had defected away from North Korea
the city was killed on he was poisoned I
mean he spent a long time in a coma
according to North Korea which they just
never updated anyone on I mean this is a
complete tragedy it's a very sad story I
don't mean to make light of it but uh
this idea that we would have young men
who think oh well I'll just go to North
Korea I mean I don't think that was
necessarily Otto's uh motivation I think
there's probably something you know very
uh masculine and very interesting and
very real about wanting to see dangerous
places with this American Soldier I
really think we have to question what is
going on where you think running across
the border of North Korea is your answer
right part of the issue is America being
on the world stage now um not having
president Trump in office not having the
same strong but slightly strange
relationship with Little Rocket Man Kim
Jong-un how are you going to get him
back yeah there's no bargaining power to
get this guy but and any of the secrets
that he might know that's a pretty
precarious situation to be in because
initially when the story broke I thought
you know what is so bad that North Korea
is the answer but now you know you may
be able to live a nice life where North
Korea says thank you for all this
information for as long as they're
willing to tolerate you right I mean
it's uh it's it's a very bizarre story I
have never been in a position where I
think I'd be better off in North Korea
to North Korea yeah it's actually pretty
concerning on the macro scale like that
an American Soldier would defect to
North Korea of all places that's really
kind of freakish that is very freaky
what kind of lack of faith you would
have in your military to do that to
North Korea you know it hasn't before
has it yeah definitely is there people
fleeing charges like this this guy was
going to get charged with assault no I
don't think fleeing charges just people
that have left the military across the
border and then have been joined they
use them for I forgot his name was uh
Ken something like that they used him
for propaganda purposes for movies right
I guess yeah
anywhere you won't be extradited from
it's somewhere like North Korea yeah
very true yeah um I don't know you'd
think people would cross that border
more often since socialism works so well
you know it's actually interesting
that's it maybe he's just so young that
he was like I don't like the American
Military anymore and I really think
socialism is it so I'll just head on
over well I'm looking for places to be
to be refugees too because I was talking
to you guys about the software uh the UK
government at the moment is passing
something called The Online safety bill
they used to call the online homes bill
so you know always the the loving
kittens and puppies act and and
basically what it means is that it puts
the UK government's uh arbitration body
for television media that stipulates you
have to be unbiased unless you left wing
which you can get away with it in charge
of every internet broadcaster so if you
guys were broadcasting in the you get
from the UK not just streaming in the UK
then you would have to have I don't know
like voshon all the time as a guest to
balance it out and and it would just
just derail the conversation of whatever
topics you were doing and and so like
our show won't operate especially
because as well the possible new prime
minister wants to criminalize
misgendering so it's like am I going to
be I don't know crashing on a couch in
Tennessee in like a year's time who
knows I mean North Korea is looking real
Sunny this time
yeah I mean obviously they're not going
to be the kind of political Freedom
you're looking for but I hear you
England is very scary right now and this
is something that a lot of progressives
neglect to acknowledge very conveniently
when they talk about the kind of
draconian speech codes that they want to
impose socially so they'll say things
like well these social media companies
might be censoring people but it's done
privately and like political correctness
uh or woke is about real problems
because it's all about just being polite
and being a different a uh excuse me
respectful and decent person of course
in Europe people are actually prosecuted
for saying things that challenge the
regime that are considered you know
offensive that are harmful and you know
quote-unquote damaging to the lgbtq
community it's easy to forget this as an
American that in the Western World there
are people who are criminally charged
for saying things that fly in the face
of left-wing Orthodoxy there are people
who are criminally charged for saying
effectively men are men and women are
women and I'm not going to call a man a
woman or a woman a man and there are
people who cheer this on right you'll
get people who will say yes you should
absolutely pass that bill because I
don't want to hear these things and I
don't want other people to hear these
things I don't even know what you're
saying but I have heard are offensive
and that's what's the most disturbing to
me that we have a complete lack of
regardless of the fact that someone
whose opinion is different than you
might not be hateful right it's just
different we live in a culture that
breeds fear which begets compliance and
I find that to be so disturbing you're
allowed to hate I mean in the United
States you're allowed to hate it's
totally cool as long as you don't commit
a crime you can hate all you want I
don't I don't like this hate crime crap
like what is the how do you know what if
they had hate in their hearts sorry but
like since when did you murder someone
out of love yeah even the crime of
passion is hatred in the moment so it's
it's complete nonsensical we've got two
pieces of legislation in the UK that
really screw us over um it's section 127
of the communications Act of 2003 that
means that if you say anything that can
be deemed quote grossly offensive over a
digital platform as long as they find
some someone who's offended by it or
even the case of count dankula they
couldn't but the the Scottish government
prosecuted him anyway you can be
prosecuted for saying something that
offends someone and then we also have
the equalities act which creates a sort
of hierarchy of protected
characteristics and the frustrating
thing is and and this is why and I don't
wish to disparage um some of the turfs
even though I find the the label radical
feminists sends a shiver up my spine it
should yeah that's the only good
feminists in a lot of ways ah my well my
friend Mary Harrington and the reaction
re feminists would seem to dissent on
that point but I don't want to get too
derailed uh the the feminists are using
the equality act legislation to fight
the reason that they are being
prosecuted under the quality act so they
just got like gender critical beliefs
added to the equality act but it's like
you're just stacking more protected
characteristics on top of each other so
it's just going to be more absurd what
you need to do is jettison the protected
characteristics framework and have
something akin to an American First
Amendment except we don't have a Britain
Constitution because that's kind of an
Athena to our country yeah you you
mentioned this thing uh also about the
the court system and dankula and this
this case if I'm not mistaken wasn't the
uh opinion handed down that context
didn't matter yes that's unbelievable
that you could have a governing legal
Authority a judge say that context
doesn't matter he took it pretty much
every court that he could and they still
wouldn't take it context matters in an
example of that is like jaywalking if of
course it's illegal but if there's a
baby in the middle of the road and cars
coming you run out in the street and
grab the baby and take him to the
sidewalk you violated the law and No
One's Gonna prosecute you for that all
the context matters exactly it's even
even illegal in the UK but but maybe
you're the land of the free yeah yeah
it's in every man for himself
um the the interesting thing though is
that we have abolished forgiveness and
Sheamus will agree with me on this when
we've become a post-christian culturally
we'd like to Pretend We're a
post-religious culture but they're just
a religion without metaphysic that's
right we we now have a one strike rule
that Brands you The Scarlet Letter
forever and the reason we do that as
well um is because we have met so many
of our material needs that now we have
moved on to the recognition economy this
is why there's so many information
sector jobs like social media or HR or
marketing and this is why the there's an
infinite number of fractionating Pride
Flags people want to codify their
personality type and demand that you
affirm them because their unsettled
screaming Consciousness their their
anxieties them doing something behind
closed doors that they know is kind of
sordid they need you to affirm them
exactly and at any time you don't it's a
transgression on their identity and so
it's akin to violence and that's the
situation We've Ended up in no that's
exactly what it is and I think you put
it perfectly they're screaming
consciences effectively when they see
you criticize them and in fact not even
necessarily just when they see you
criticizing them when they just see you
living and acting like a normal person
having a normal life and not engaged in
the degenerate nonsense that they're
engaged in they are bothered by it
because you in that moment are a proxy
for their conscience they see what they
could be so this idea that what I do
behind closed doors doesn't matter ah
yes of course your bedroom door has
magical properties such as that it
totally erases the consequences of your
actions from your psyche and when you go
into the outside world your behavior is
not modified in the way you interact
with the rest of us is it modified or
effective by what you've done in there
it's nonsense yeah you need to create
that whatever whatever sort of thing
you're doing as being the new societal
standard so that you aren't tripping
around it like a Minefield in every
conversation you have and then you need
people to celebrate it so that it makes
you feel better about yourself because
just being accepted not being a special
little snowflake is not enough if you
have crippling social anxiety yeah I
think that's the important uh argument
for religion I think I know there are
criticisms of organized religion but
having something larger than yourself
means that you don't need to seek
affirmation from a crowd of people or
whoever's trendy right now whoever says
well I know how you can feel like you're
doing the right thing and we'll praise
you for doing this like it's such a
damaging way to live your life that I am
surprised that I'm not surprised because
our culture thrives on insecurity uh
it's funny to me that they can't look
themselves in the face and see oh I can
see that the cycle I'm trapped in I'm
never good enough for this ideology that
actually hates me and would be fine if I
got destroyed because it betters their
own agenda yeah well and also oh sorry
I'll let you jump in a second because I
want to hear what you said that thinking
about that being people being used as
pawns to forward a political agenda like
if if uh what like someone that
identifies as a trans female is is goes
in into a shooting range and then is
killed by the police it's like oh Trans
rights you know and it's like what do
you mean the support they needed like
the justifications become insane because
we are willing to defy logic to protect
certain people if they fall into certain
certain ideological classes it's totally
remember seven victims yes yeah no
what's that yeah so after the uh the
Audrey oh yeah yeah that's exactly what
I was just thinking about yeah exactly
so in Tennessee when those uh Christian
children were murdered by a person who
identified as transgender because they
identified as transgender left-wing
singers who had invaded a capitol
building I believe was the capital they
invaded in the state of Tennessee as
well they were saying that there were
seven victims there because they
considered the shooter to have been a
victim and this is because like
victimhood in their mind is merely a
question of identity if you are in a
victim class everything you do is a
manifestation of your victimhood and if
you're in an oppressor class everything
you do is a manifestation of your
oppressiveness so of course this person
was a victim they have to be a victim
they're always going to be a victim and
there's glory in being the victim right
yes being a welcome means to them for
them for them I wouldn't say for us uh
for them being a victim means that
somebody is going to Champion you and
and give you special privileges and I
have to be more understanding because I
couldn't possibly understand what you're
going through in the hardships and this
that and the other instead of a culture
that that encourages you to know
yourself well to live by strong values
they're saying just completely fall
apart and then someone else will tell
you when you're okay or not I think
there's some that value to equity like
I'm all about equality over Equity like
you ever see that that Meme of the three
people the short guy the medium-sized
guy and the tall guy trying to look over
a fence and only the tall guy can see
but there's three boxes and each of them
have one box so the tall guy can see the
medium guy and the small guy can't see
so or it's the other one two the medium
guy and tall guy I can see a small guy
can't see so they say equity and they
give the boxes of the tall guy to the
small guy and now the small guy now they
can all see but so I understand a little
bit of that sometimes maybe man but not
like an entire Society built around
kneecapping the best among us to propel
those that can't I just to your example
what they're saying is the tall guy
should have to uh kneel down and not
look at look not look past the fence at
all he's got to watch this baseball game
for too long he doesn't need it he can
still see without the box so they take
his box away and give it to someone
they're saying that's not enough
but hold on but this this is also really
important because a lot of people fail
to recognize this even if you want to
buy into this world for you we say like
people need to be you have to be given
exactly uh what they need in order to be
equal to other people how on Earth do
you have any idea what it is about a
person that makes them unequal to other
people how could you possibly say you
have an answer to that question people
are unbelievably complex and intricate
the idea that you could just like
rearrange material reality to the point
where everyone's on an equal playing
field is complete nonsense and in the
United States all men are born created
equal Like That explicit well we're not
all the same it's because we left your
country we're not all the same but we're
they're born in um you're in an
excrement we are born inextricably
dependent from one another that's true
and this is this is why and this and to
tie up the the materialism versus
metaphysics what you're approximity what
higher ideal you both serve but can
never be too excessive in trying to
embody but not circumventing the reason
Audrey Hale was lionized as a martyr to
the trans cause is twofold and this is
this is why I think Marxism and
liberalism are twin cheeks of the same
materialistic backside uh Marxism in all
of the Marxist literature you will see
that because the superstructure the the
oppressive engineered uh inequities by
capitalism is inescapable then if you
set up a revolution all Revolution is
just self-defense you'll see this in
engel's marks and Rosa Luxembourg
revolutionary minus the Polish the other
side of that is that with liberalism
you're right you can never actually
quantify how much Freedom someone has if
Freedom autonomy maximum material
benefits with minimal social Reliance is
the goal like Rousseau would do right
you can't itemize that all you can do is
go on an eternal Crusade of things which
are seen as impediments to you being a
fully autonomous individual this is
something called comprehensive
liberalism Claire Chambers has written
about it she's a total mad woman go down
a rabbit hole um my colleague Carl
insteadios with a great video on the
website and so this is why they're very
similar both have a Promethean ambition
both seek to generate endless insatiable
desires they use Tech to do so this is
why the recognition economy has come out
of the material deficit economy all you
can do to correct that measure is have
humility in proximity to the highest
possible love which I have London would
say is God beautiful beautiful and to
also reference Augustine he said that
man has as many Masters as he does vices
and so this idea of freedom as we
generally conceive of it merely being a
product of the ability to have multiple
choices without reference to your
internal discipline is totally
nonsensical and speaking of that kind of
world view and what it leads to we have
a story here of a pro-euthanasia
activist who's been convicted in the
Netherlands of sending suicide kits to
1600 people this is the inevitable
outgrowth of materialism the belief that
freedom is simply a product of making
multiple choices and has nothing to do
with what the right or wrong choice is
as well as a person's virtuous
predispositions or lack thereof or what
man is meant to do and whether he's free
to flourish in the role that he was
built for rather than the one he has
chosen for himself irrationally the
activist Alex s was selling kits to
people who didn't qualify for the legal
assisted suicide program and according
to the court the activist convinced
people that the drugs were painless but
in reality they suffered quote severe
distress and panic which led to a
gruesome death but it actually gets even
worse than that in April the Netherlands
announced plans to expand the assisted
suicide and euthanasia program to allow
children ages 1 to 12 year olds to be
what eligible yeah what a a one-year-old
can opt for suicide medically he can't
his parents can what that's murder you
can't a one-year-old cannot opt in to
get themselves killed that's a parent
doing it to the kid yep yeah it's it's
sickening it's completely sickening this
is this is what my friend Mary
Harrington has referred to as the uh
this war on Imago day it's the idea that
the human body is sacred in any way
shape or form and you can't just exit it
or mutilate it at any time and what
we're seeing in relation to materialism
is it's either the body is a prison
um not everything is gnosticism people
you know get that get that out but but
the the the trans identity is a form of
gnosticism where your body is a fleshy
prison and you have to approximate it to
feel you truly are inside that's right
uh is true so there's no sacredness
about the body you were given you just
play mix and match with the appendages
until you feel okay or there's the
attitude that your body is kind of a
vessel of gratification it's just it's
just the means by which you feel around
in a purely sensory world and so when
you stop being capable of that sensation
when you stop being able to be pleasure
seeking because you have a terminal
illness or you're old or you're just
depressed and you don't feel anything
anymore then they say well it's
perfectly logically consistent to exit
and their only complaint is that you are
suffering not that you are achieving the
ultimate suffering which is just the
extinguishing of your conscience exactly
well okay that's a very important point
and I would frame it very similarly once
you have made the meaning of life
pleasure once a person is no longer able
to or as the very least less capable of
experiencing subjectively pleasurable
States then their life no longer has
meaning if the purpose of life if the
meaning of life goes deeper than your
own particular emotions about the
situation that you're in then no amount
of suffering actually justifies ending
the life of a human being directly and
intentionally yeah this is classic
Sultan it's an existentialism this is
and then if you ever want to sort of
Escape
um I've suffered with depressional
throughout my life I'm not going to
minimize it but if you ever want to get
perspective read the accounts of the
people that have suffered the most and
you will probably never suffer and they
have come through it with sincere
metaphysical convictions and faith in
humanity Victor frankels brought about
this that Soldier Nixon's written about
this if they can survive a gulag or a
concentration camp you can survive not
being able to access PornHub in your
stickers
and Utah blocked it because kids weren't
able to look at it what an important
detail on that story and but before
before I passed you and I just want to
mention here uh with what you just said
um I agree with you that when you look
at people who have experienced the most
tremendous suffering they they tend to
be deferential to a higher power they
believe in Morality they believe in
meaning and of course that's because
experience is an expensive classroom and
those who have paid the greatest Price
often have the greatest knowledge but
also because I believe those situations
actually select for people who have a
deeper view of what existence is that
goes beyond pleasure because if you
don't view that to begin with or you
don't come to believe that at some point
through that experience you're just
gonna it's a crucible for Spiritual
formation yeah well being in the gym man
with a personal trainer being like
you're 12 more 12 more reps now we're
going up wait now we're going 25 pounds
that's like hell it's like being in a
kind of personal hell for a moment just
a moment but after coming out of it it's
like I don't want to kill myself anymore
I've already been through it man God is
good like this life is great
is why MSNBC came out the other day and
said lifting weights is right wing
because you're an independent thinker
once you once you master your own body
you're not contingent on other people's
stimulants or or Pleasures to try and
sedate that screaming conscience then
then the the universal homogeneous State
can't have you in their clutches sure
man yeah I gotta get way more right wing
I'll have to hit the gym
one point that you mentioned here is
it's like your own personal hell there's
something here and there's actually
something that touches such an important
part no no I know but but this this
touch is on an important part of like
the Christian tradition which is dying
to yourself it's like to describe it as
hell in some senses describe it as like
a small death like you are willfully
embracing a form of death but what is
the outcome of that a resurrection your
muscles get stronger you actually
strengthen yourself because you
willfully embraced that small death
literally tearing your muscles bleeding
on the inside so that it can forge and
regrow stronger and bigger yeah that
small death has like led to a small
Resurrection in a sense and I think I
think we see that with with uh all
productive things that are painful right
if if you really buckled down and do
your job even though it's difficult
there's like a small death you feel oh
it's so beautiful outside I don't want
to work right now but then when all is
said and done and you've created this
it's like this moment of Resurrection
you've created something beautiful
because you willingly Embrace that yeah
I think there's a resistance to
accepting that Gloria comes through
struggle right yeah yeah is through a
lot of things and there's a fear of
hardship right so when we talk about
censoring people's language or saying
you know you have to call me by these
things you need to you need to make me
feel good about myself we are
encouraging a culture that is avoiding
Challenge and avoiding personal growth
through Challenge and I think that is
what's most devastating to uh to people
today is that you can never feel true
satisfaction without really feeling
you've achieved something and sometimes
achievement comes at a cost I won't I
agree with you I think you can't
minimize you know how how crippling
depression anxiety some of the emotional
states that people go through can be on
the other hand uh working through your
struggle is ultimately how you become a
better and stronger person version of
yourself and it gives you a perspective
active that you are I personally feel
like meant to have right you you want to
have insight into the world that makes
you more in touch with The Human
Condition I think about meditation
that's another struggle because it's
easy to think it's easy to get
distracted and think about the colors
you see or the noise you're hearing but
to have no thoughts that's a challenge
and it is hard that's why prayer is a
lot easier because all you do is
externalize your thoughts and you give
it up to the big man upstairs and he can
walk you through it rather than try and
force yourself to be completely blind
you just bend your conscience out and
you actually have a dialogue with
someone that can help you out but and
there's also I would say there's also a
discipline and difficulty to prayer uh
which is kind of touching on on part of
what you're saying which is even though
I don't like recommend the form of
meditation you're describing I agree
that there's something very difficult
about not just allowing your internal
monologue to drag you everywhere without
taking a moment to reflect about what
you're thinking about what you're
orienting yourself towards it's really
important uh I believe to develop a
prayer life in part to escape that just
constantly being led around by that that
almost nagging that like very ADHD jump
from subject to subject to subject is
based on whatever interests why I don't
pray what I Don't Pray by saying things
in my thoughts I just have no thoughts
is because I feel like it's polarizing
to choose this is what it's going to be
like with no thought there's no I'm not
deciding it's got to be this now I I get
concerned about my polarizing my
behavior in my mind that's interesting
so so here's what I would say
um
when you're allowing yourself and we all
do this right and this is what we're
trying to escape in some sense when we
allow ourselves to just be dragged
around from thought to thought in that
instance we're actually not choosing
what we're thinking about right we're
just being led and I think to jump to
another state where you're trying to
suppress all thought I would say you're
also just not choosing a particular
thought and so that's why I would say
like prayer is actually
um the opposite of just letting yourself
being led around and it does require
choice but but um your thoughts being
dragged everywhere doesn't require a
choice right you're just kind of letting
it happen but it gets to a point where
you're not suppressing the thoughts
anymore they just stop coming into your
head and it'll be like 40 minutes will
go you'll be like five seconds and then
you realize you're thinking you're like
okay let it go no thought and then like
some time goes by and you're like oh oh
there's a oh I was thinking for a few
minutes or a few seconds okay let it go
and then all of a sudden it's like
longer eight seconds then it's like 20
seconds you have no thought then all of
a sudden you can do it for five minutes
and you're like whoa then like all your
emotions they're back to Baseline yeah
well it's it's interesting we'll have to
discuss it because again I've made my
thoughts about like that form of
meditation station clear but it'd be a
cool discussion for the after show too I
think to get into some of that stuff uh
and then with reference to what uh
Hannah Claire was saying about making
yourself better I just want to mention
this before we move on from the topic
you made this point becoming a stronger
better version of yourself if you
believe that there is a Telus that there
is a purpose that there is a reason you
are here than achieving that purpose is
what you're supposed to do and a
struggle is something that you may have
to embrace in order to reach that
fulfillment to in order to fulfill your
purpose uh and you can get pleasure from
that like of course naturally there's a
natural pleasure that comes from doing
things the right way and when you
develop virtue there's like a pleasure
that a person can get from doing
something virtuous that said I think the
modern conceptualization which is just
feel good about things of course can't
contend with that and what ends up
happening is your your mission is not
necessarily become a better version of
yourself it's just that maximize
positive experiences and minimize uh
displeasurable experiences and so what
that results in is basically a
philosophy that I don't think can argue
against the best possible state to be in
is a simulation where everything goes
well for you and not living in the real
world doing difficult but important
things where you get whatever you want
because it's completely about
self-indulgence and in that you are
never able to experience true Joy or
happiness because it's all about
momentary immediate pleasure right I
mean some of the challenges that we're
talking about like when you bring up
working out is that long term you're
going to feel the benefits of it it's
not that every single day when you're
lifting weights is super fun right
you're exhausted you're tired it's that
ultimately these things are worth it and
that you stay on the path because you
know you're achieving something great
through the sacrifice and struggle that
it takes I do like yesterday I was
playing Drops of Jupiter by Train on and
I start crying man I think about my mom
and he's singing about his mom in that
song and she died I guess and her Soul's
out there and it comes it's just like
but then I feel like it's like yeah it
hurts and it's painful it's sad but then
I'm normal like um it's okay it's okay
you don't have to put you can bear Xanax
in your in your brain yeah yeah I know
that's an interesting point too like
trying to get through things without
medicating yourself but also not to get
addicted to the pain because it can
become like the crying I was like I want
to I couldn't keep doing it I'm like oh
I feel and I want I'm like no just
breathe and kind of let it out you know
it comes you don't you don't force it
onto yourself just happens yeah more
difficult is not necessarily better I
agree with you right like you you can't
just make it about embracing something
difficult because sometimes something
which is more difficult is not
necessarily the best path for you yeah
don't mostly yourself live is the ideal
instead yeah that's the way to go yeah
yeah that's a fair question don't Marty
yourself live as the ideal instead oh
yeah dude well we were we were just
talking a moment ago uh about jumping
from thought to thought uh versus you
know trying to push all the thoughts out
of your head our next story involves a
man who I'm not sure which category to
place him in there is this someone who
doesn't have thoughts is this someone
who's LED around from thought to thought
I am not sure but he is our president
the one and only Joe Biden and his
administration says a surprise surprise
they think that scotus got it wrong
after striking down student loan
forgiveness of course he does I mean
it's ridiculous if you want to sit here
and make the argument that student loan
forgiveness is a good program I'll
disagree with you for some reasons I've
laid out last night in which I'll
summarize again in a moment here but
ultimately the idea that it is an
infringement of people's rights that the
Supreme Court is failing to stick to
constitutional ideals by not allowing
Joe Biden to redistribute wealth from
people who didn't receive higher
education or who paid off their loans to
people who did receive higher education
and or didn't pay off their loans or I
should say and didn't pay off their own
not and or
is totally insane so I rattled off some
statistics last night people who
graduate with a PhD earn something like
000 a year as their median income and
their unemployment rate is about 1.1
percent people with uh Masters will earn
a median income about 78 000 their their
uh unemployment rate is slightly higher
but nothing too terrible than when you
go down to people who only have a high
school education their median income is
about 38 000 a year and they have a four
point something percent uh unemployment
rate so the idea that people who haven't
received higher education who are making
significantly less money and have a
higher unemployment rate should have
their wealth redistributed in order to
pay for people who did receive a higher
education and who are now in the
workforce with a higher earning
potential despite taking anywhere
between four and eight years out of the
workforce in order to attain that degree
and in many cases paid for some of their
living expenses rather than just their
education with those loans uh I think
it's just totally insane it's totally
unfair aside from being unconstitutional
I gotta argue that that should be the
status I gotta ask because I talked to
my mother about this couple days ago I
was like I'm not comfortable she's like
oh yeah they're starting to stop him
from but Ian you need and I'm like I'm
not comfortable getting other people to
tax money to pay off my debt and she's
like no it's only the billionaires taxes
that are you getting used not true so
this is the media I mean she watches
MSNBC yeah I guess they're just kind of
subtly not telling you the guys that
make 16 bucks an hour at McDonald's are
going to have to pay your taxes to for
me to get my student loans paid I mean
I'm fortunately I'm not in that bracket
now it's all well so what happened is I
got an email from the Department he's
not Biden he's not even doing it with
his mouth he's doing with the Department
of Education I got an email from them
that said we don't we think the Supreme
Court got it wrong this is like four
days ago or something so we're gonna do
it anyway but we're gonna do it with
people that are making up to 65 000 a
year or something like that and uh if
you if you don't want it opt out but
otherwise we're just gonna do it well I
think part of this for Biden is it's
it's a liver it's a it's a make or break
issue for him because he campaigned so
hard on I will get your student loans
forgiven right and so now we're getting
desperate we're getting closer to
election season and he needs to make
progress on this issue otherwise a lot
of his young voter base is going to say
but you said you'd pay off my debt and
you didn't I mean I have never
understood how Joe Biden is a viable
candidate for Democrats anyways but it's
important to note how big of an issue
this was this was a deciding factor for
young voters understandably so because I
don't I don't disagree with Sheamus on
the other hand the reality is if you
have tons of student loan debt because
you were told hey go take out a loan pay
for your education and it'll all work
out and you are feeling the consequence
of that I would also be looking for a
way to get out of this right I would
also be looking for help and Joe Biden
is failing on that front yeah not that
he shouldn't but you can see where it
becomes one one underlying theme of all
of our conversations tonight has been
the fostering of dependency by being
Godless materially contingent and now
the reason they're pushing for this and
I think I think we've got a model over
in the UK is because universe closed
captioning not available
in the UK to go to university then the
Cameron years pushed it up so they made
you stay in higher education until 18 so
they could fudge the unemployment
numbers and also because student loans
are a lot less and the taxpayer
guaranteed so they've just jumped them
up significantly I think they've doubled
them but I paid about 9 000 pounds a
year plus a maintenance loan that's
means adjusted so about four thousand
pounds so I've left about 40 000 pounds
in debt in total and we pay that back
over the course of about 30 years so we
wouldn't pay back until about 50. and
what they want to do is get you into the
institution which engenders a certain
kind of managerial monitor it's a
self-propagating managerial class like
like James Burnham would have talked
about and then you're in you're sort of
imbibed in sectionality and you become
the perfect kind of compliant corporate
drone who says whatever they can to get
ahead and what Brian wants here is to
create a dependent class both they want
to vote him in so they can alleviate the
debt and if you have a lot of debt and
of course you want the government to
come and manage the economy to get rid
of it and also self-propagate more
people going to University so they're
not as scared about racking up all this
debt so then they're more compliant with
zdix in the future it's it's a it's a
genius self-propagation strategy yeah
um no wonder the Democrats want to push
it I think it is also interesting this
idea of getting people massively in debt
to the point where they don't have the
kind of economic leverage that they
ordinarily would without also giving
them some kind of property to show for
it I mean this is absolutely massive
this is one of the reasons I'm somewhat
sympathetic to the people who say they
want student loans to be forgiven
there's actually a few reasons
ultimately I don't agree with it for the
reasons I laid out earlier you make way
more money with the degree people are
making less money shouldn't have to pay
your degree off you still generally end
up making way more over the course of
your life than the degree ends up
costing uh but that said I I believe in
property ownership I believe that one of
the best economic strategies is to
create the conditions for the largest
amount of people to have property as
possible so that everyone has a stake in
the system everyone does actually have a
a material stake in the future as well I
think when you're a nation of renters it
becomes a lot more difficult to get
people to care about a neighborhood or a
region and this is also part of why it's
so Insidious that organizations like
BlackRock and a lot of these investor
buyers have been swooping in and getting
all of the real estate in this country
and driving prices up for residential
owners and so I'm I'm sympathetic to the
argument even though I don't agree with
student loan forgiveness that we have
effectively created a class of people
who have the worst of Both Worlds
they're heavily in debt so they lack
leverage but they also don't along with
that debt have the leverage that comes
along with property ownership it's even
worse in the UK so in 1997 before Tony
Blair did education and immigration
reforms house prices were three times
median income now it's 11. oh my
goodness yep we only build 200 000 homes
a year we have net intake a 1.1 million
immigrants plus the people they're
battery farming in these hotels
migration watch UK has estimated that
because and this is the office for
National statistics that have found that
um migration is the leading cause of
population increase in the UK because
we've got a sub-replacement birth rate
as to most places most Western countries
yes and and higher education is the
cause of that I spoke to Stephen Shaw a
documentary filmmaker and he said that
this is one of the main reasons why
people are delaying having kids is
because they're spending up until their
mid-20s their Peak fertility is in
universities but um migration watch
found that by 2046 the rated population
increase that the UK is experiencing
will have to have 15 to 18 new cities
the size of Birmingham to accommodate
that we can't build it and and the
reason they're not building it this is
the final point is that 25 of of the
conservative policies donors are
property developers so they have the
perverse incentive to both keep prices
high enough that they're making a return
on investment but then keep a steady
stream of of inflated demand so they
keep building these terrible new houses
that are unfit for living and are
basically just knocked up new builds
where the whether like garden fences are
like that so it's the worst of Both
Worlds in my country yeah um I'd also
like to mention one more thing which is
that Biden student loan repayment uh
changes could cost around 475 billion
dollars we've been talking a lot about
the negative economic impact in an
abstract though valid way however these
are the material figures 475 billion
dollars the federal just print that in
an afternoon it's fine guys consequences
it never has right when is printing way
too much money ever gone badly for a
country
oh yeah I mean they just act like money
doesn't mean anything these numbers are
ridiculous and I think that's partially
because
um in my opinion the Democrat Party
relies on fixing things in the immediate
short term to maintain power and they
just kick the problems down the line in
fact they're more likely to blame
someone else right right
um I I think it's uh
I think it's a broken system and I am
sad for the people who have to deal with
the consequences but I don't think that
student loan uh debt forgiveness is is
the answer the way that it's being
proposed uh and and part of that for me
is it all goes back to a huge cultural
shift I mean you might be able to speak
this more than I can but uh our our
education system demands that you make
it through 12th grade and then we go to
12th grade you're supposed to leave and
go to college you're supposed to go four
degree and increasingly say Well if you
really want to make more money you
should get a master's grade so that's an
additional two uh one to two years right
and well let's not forget about the
medical professions and going to law
school uh so you're in school forever
creating intense debt and also being
reliant on a system I think that the
American education system needs a
complete overhaul that encourages
independent thought because it shouldn't
current and current it should encourage
uh self-dependence and self-reliance I
think that is is ultimately what I don't
like and it's why it's important you
have these conversations about well if
you don't go to college with your
options and in America we desperately
need people to go into to the trade
which you can have in a successful
living without taking on debt and in
some ways have a more free life right if
you are Shackled to student debt you
have to be conscious of that in in how
you financially plan for your life even
though you have this high-paying degree
uh whereas if you are able to start
making significant amounts of money at a
young age imagine all the things that
you could do and the Investments you
make and the changes that you could have
yeah if you want to work on the uh if
you want to be an electrician you can
also be a YouTuber you can be an artist
and a Craftsman now in this world and
you can make a lot of money and you
don't need to go to school for it you
can learn the trade online that's the
overhaul I think we need is people need
to take it seriously the data is there
it is available on the internet well you
shot yourself the animated the age 12 or
something yeah I started when I was 12.
yeah and you're like now you're like a
quadrillionaire until YouTube locks you
out of your account of course yeah no
yes
so uh we're still not waiting there were
um for people who don't know story short
yeah so I uh have a large YouTube
channel called Freedom Tunes we have 700
877 000 subscribers I make animated
cartoons there what happened was I have
a podcast on Rumble called shamer there
was another YouTube channel that was
pirating all of our content and
uploading it without our permission
permission we've been trying to flag
them to get them taken down because we
have our own shamer channel on YouTube
that we are posting Clips to and it's
been overshadowed in the algorithm by
this imposter
and so myself and many people were kind
of flagging to try to get it you know to
to bring it to YouTube's attention
nothing happened and uh so I just
flagged some of their their content and
then YouTube did take some of it down
and uh because I was able to prove that
this is content that was mine originally
that came from my Rummel Channel and
then we flagged some more of it and what
happened was and by we I mean me I was
just sat at my computer and flagged a
couple more videos uh and just showed
that they were uploaded without my
permission where they came from
originally they were the exact same
videos exact same titles exact same
lengths not mirrored or anything like
that uh and YouTube said that the claims
were fraudulent and that it was removing
all of the channels associated with the
Channel that I made the claim from so I
got an email for every YouTube channel
that I run from that email address that
had been taken down and it didn't
mention Freedom tunes and freedom Tunes
is still up but all related channels are
deleted and I cannot log into Freedom
Tunes every single time I try to there's
no interface for me to do anything it
just takes me back to my other Google
accounts so I I've reached out to the
people at Google to see if we can get
this fixed I've reached out to the
people at YouTube I tweeted about it a
little bit earlier today let's uh hope
and pray that we're able to get this
sorted out my favorite part of this was
YouTube responded to you on Twitter
saying no no you don't understand you
just have to take down your your
fraudulent content like and I was like
oh yeah
content I was like no you don't
understand like I was accused of making
a false copyright claim when I didn't
the claim was like blatantly blatantly
true like I posted my video on Rumble
which was identical to the video this
person posted on YouTube a day later and
had the same title and was the exact
same content all I can so yeah we're
locked out of Freedom tunes right now
because of all this all if I can see is
if you if you flag the same video from
three different accounts they're like
hey you can only flag no yeah but that's
not what happened that's not what
happened I I used so I was using the the
channel was Eclipse channel for my
shamer podcast and uh I I flagged it
from there because that seemed to be the
most appropriate channel to do it from
since that's the one that was being
overshadowed in the algorithm by this
other shamer channel uh and yeah they
said all the other channels linked to it
were being removed open it up guys
because he's been stressed yeah I'm not
good we need to get the chance do you
think they were just punishing you for
having Rumble exclusive I don't know
about that because I it also affected my
freedom Tunes Channel you're right that
that could still be a punishment I don't
want to assume that this was like
politically motivated or malicious I
think it's from YouTube yeah I know well
I I think here's the thing it seems to
me like something that could just be a
massive mistake here's the thing it's I
don't know if they have an AI algorithm
doing this if they do I still think it's
really remarkable that it would consider
this claim fraudulent considering it is
the exact same video both places
uploaded a day before on my channel
um and also oh by the way this channel
that was uploading my stuff now they
just uploaded his full Stephen Crowder
video so I don't know how much more
obvious it has to be that a channel is
fake and pirating content but it's still
up there and my channels are all taken
down and we can't get into Freedom too
no no you're mistaken because you're
hosting for Tim this week
he's taking over your channel right
yeah so I thought that you wouldn't be
him actually the show would get the raw
end of the deal of the Irish Catholic
Exchange program
together that's right Tim Tim would uh
send his Irish Catholic away over to
England and then you guys would get one
back here now we're building the same
room together because I sent Tim away I
want to just before we move on to the
next topic um I want to tap out on uh
student loans because what I think the
biggest problem is that one it's not
cool to go tax a bunch of people that
aren't asking for it to pay off my loans
that's not cool it's also not cool to
print a bunch of money without anybody's
Authority because it diminishes all of
our purchasing power makes the dollar
worth eight ninety eight cents or 96
cents or whatever that's not cool what
would be interesting is if they told the
loan agencies we're not giving you the
interest back all that collateral loan
all this compounding interest you're not
getting any of it back I would even go
so far as to say you're not getting any
of the loans back and now that might
destroy the economy so I have look too
deep into what that would do how it
would rattle the system but I think the
compound interest is predatory I don't
think it's ethical it's usurious and I
think that our government would have a
right to say you're not getting the
compound interest back and then cut it
out of everyone's debt no no printing I
I would tend to agree I I think there
are a lot of problems with interest
especially compounding interest I
understand that because we have a
economy and a government that's always
inflating its own currency that interest
does become necessary to issue loans but
I agree with you like the compounding
interest stuff the idea of just making
absorbitant amounts of money off of
these loans especially when they're
federally guaranteed just seems entirely
backwards to me the government's
guaranteeing these loans I I don't know
how you can make the same justification
it would seem to me that in that
situation what you would have to do if
the loan was federally guaranteed is
ensure that the only kind of Interest
imposed would be interest that kept the
loan uh study with inflation so that the
people who gave it out didn't lose value
in the long term or lose adjusted money
but where they weren't able to profit
immensely off of something where they
really don't have any risk because the
government has told them that they're
going to get the money back regardless
if I can make one one small point on
perverse profits incentives over in the
UK side we don't have the same level of
interest on our loans as you guys do and
they're not nearly as expensive but what
we do have is universities knowing that
the the budget is government guaranteed
running up a massive debt and so what
they do is because foreign students pay
much more they Mass import students from
China and India mainly the very wealthy
students over there that can pay up
front and then they build loads of
student accommodation rather than the
houses we were talking about the the
charge exhaustion prices so what ends up
happening is uh Native British students
even though they're paying less they're
getting less quality education they're
competing for the same spots and they're
getting lower quality student
accommodation and even their student
accommodation is more expensive because
it's scarce so I just think running the
universities as a for-profit Enterprise
hasn't gone as well as as some would
hope yeah well no it's interesting
there's a similar problem that actually
happens with State schools in the U.S if
you're born in a specific state if
you're a resident of that state you live
there your whole life you are able to
get a discount on the tuition so of
course they have an economic incentive
to accept more students from out of
state because they're going to end up
paying the full tuition price uh without
ever you know having to give that
discount and speaking of hunting for
discounts we you know a certain special
somebody transitions on this show his
luggage for free that was that was that
was Michael Knowles levels
thank you Michael Knowles hopes to be
Sheamus cogn level smooth at some point
but uh the non-binary uh X Biden
official Sam Britton was on a secret
taxpayer funded trip at the time of his
luggage theft what an unbelievably fun
story here so yes Sam Britton of the
Department of energy was on a tax-funded
trip at the time when he stole the
luggage that was or the incident where
it was actually captured on footage in
Nevada Nevada I can't believe I said
Nevada who says Nevada it's Nevada no
it's Nevada okay I don't know it was
like a speech impediment there for a
moment there
um but yeah so the trip was caught on
camera I believe this is the the third
time or at least he's been accused three
times of taking suitcases from women
um and then wearing
so it wasn't enough that he was on a
taxpayer-funded trip he also had to get
free luggage so I guess one question I
have is does this guy just not pack a
bag before he goes on these trips and
maybe the reason that like he's ended up
just wearing different clothing isn't
just uh you know like self-expression as
he would put it but it's like this is
what's in the luggage you just get
luggage from the airport and then you
put the clothes on and like the clothing
that was in the luggage well Eva how
much is he stealing to continually find
clothes that fit like is he just playing
a numbers game or is he doing the
Buffalo Bill thing of where he'll go are
you about size 14 club and then get the
what no I have no idea but I don't think
he's spending all that much time
thinking about the luggage he gets
because there was a hilarious story a
little while ago Hannah Claire and I
were talking about this before uh we we
went on air but it was basically
determined that the clothing that he was
wearing was clothing which came from the
suitcase of a woman who was a fashion
designer yeah so she had made a bunch of
different uh beautiful dresses for
fashion Expo she went from Tanzania
she's from Tanzania she's based in
Houston
and traveled to DC
was supposed to show her clothes as sort
of a business deal for her and couldn't
do it because her bag went missing at
Reagan Airport and uh when she heard
about Sam Britain's arrest she said I'm
gonna look this up and recognize the
clothes that he has been wearing because
they're not just run of the mill you can
get them at the Gap they are very unique
meanwhile so she went she went on
Twitter for this and I was just like I I
was shortly thereafter contacted by the
FBI who was like please give us more
information and then after that I I
don't know if they're actually connected
but uh Sam Burton was arrested as a
fugitive from Justice he lives in
Maryland because he works for DC in
connection to someone's luggage going
missing from a DC airport and I find
this to be so funny because what were
the odds I mean it wasn't like he just
wore them you know casually to the
office he went on to like the Trevor
projects had him on for some award he's
wearing this thing can you imagine being
this woman being like I not just own
that I made that that is my piece of
clothing but shouldn't we as a nation
all share with one another Hannah Claire
I don't don't you think it's a bit
stingy of her to say
you know I don't know it's like I always
say uh you didn't build that uh somebody
else made that happen my I quote Norm
Macdonald here and that sounds like some
bleep commy gobbledygook um I'd also
like to draw attention to sambron again
I'm just gonna go on the ad hominemian
because you're setting a fantastic
example that that mug shot is the sleep
paralysis demon though my name is
Matt Damon could play that guy he's a
little older now but then what do you
want to do you think it could be could
be an interesting kind of Thriller yeah
dude Lex Freeman made a hilarious
observation it wasn't even a joke he's
like you go to the airport you wait for
two hours standing in line taking your
shoes off taking your bag out and then
when you get out of the airport you get
all done just take whatever bag you want
yeah and it's true there's like you
could you could walk out of there with
like 40 bags I mean not if you have more
than one someone will probably be like
hey but there's no security at the bags
they just come out and anyone can grab
anything it's crazy you know what though
I hear you but please don't give them
don't make anything to make the airport
more of a hassle with that like I think
the baggage thing is us saying this is a
this is a price we are willing to pay to
just not have to deal with the TSA
anymore not have to deal with any more
bureaucracy just let me go I'm off the
plane let me leave but we didn't even
need that level of bureaucracy when we
were high across society and when we
started mainstreaming degeneracy and
importing compatible cultures where High
trust is not that same thing the social
texture phrase and so you need
increasing levels of bureaucracy to
micromanage the behaviors of a dependent
population and I I would agree with you
but it's not even just that I mean these
bureaucracies aren't even effective at
combating what they're there to protect
us from the TSA has failed like 98 of
its audits to try to press off by
incompetent diversity hires like this so
unfortunately they decide to out
themselves I mean yeah he is one of one
of our leading nuclear Minds in this
country I don't know what you're talking
about oh yeah from the radiation Point
yeah seriously no one I mean I think
it's worth pointing out that uh you're
saying before is he just following
people around and guessing that they're
his size he is he is specifically uh
looking for female luggage one of the
examples was uh he stole a a duffel bag
what I believe was Vera Bradley if you
if you know Vera Bradley it's all very
feminine Prince this person is
specifically targeting women to steal
from them this is bizarre and yet the
Biden Administration just tried to
pretend it wasn't happening they sort of
said oh well not employed by us like we
couldn't say and now we know that
actually he was acting this way while on
duty for the government well look I mean
come on stealing luggage sniffing kids
they're not that far outside of one
another in terms of like a Defiance of
normal behavioral expectations so I I I
I don't even think it's the Biden
administration's worst Scandal by any
stretch isn't that true not the weirdest
thing and by scale I'm not saying well
there are worse scandals because there's
political options now I'm just talking
about like the weird things people in
the Bible Administration have done I
don't think this is the weirdest thing
we have a vice president who cackles
over Venn diagrams and who loves yellow
school buses and gleefully exclaims it
like she's a children's population
control they put satanists in charge of
monkey pox response I mean did they well
this is yeah this is I mean and of
course the monkey pox thing we won't get
too much into detail about that just
because uh probably says if it is a
family-friendly show but I just find it
interesting that the thing is that is
associated with the spread of monkey pox
was like the one thing that we were not
willing to prohibit because we believe
so deeply in human freedom and political
Liberty when we were willing to tell
people not to go to their jobs or to
visit loved ones in the hospital or
attend funerals for loved ones during
the covet pandemic it just shows you
where the priorities of the regime are
we just don't want to be big at it I
mean I think it's worth noting we still
talked about this before the show but
Sanford is openly I don't know gender
fluid all all sorts of interesting
hobbies uh he was featured in like a
kink magazine I find it
not at all surprising that this person
is clearly not bound by any social norms
or values exhibitionist kleptomaniac
right yes okay that's important open
about this uh he does not believe in the
world that you live in he does not
believe in uh anything else I'm sure I
am getting his pronouns wrong
of course he's stealing bags everywhere
this this last like moment of trust that
we all take our own bags off the
carousel doesn't not apply to him
because he doesn't need to be a part of
that and it's hard for me not to read a
level of entitlement into this yeah a
level of entitlement I mean I think
that's true whenever you see somebody
defying social expectations which are
otherwise otherwise reasonable and uh
acceptable and make sense every now and
again I get that there are barriers that
need to be broken down right you know I
like the idea of chesterton's fence when
you find a fence figure out what it was
for before you tear it down and
sometimes you know maybe that fences for
something bad and it's okay to tear it
down I'm not saying no one should ever
defy expectation but what I am saying is
when someone is defying expectations
when they're tearing down fences that
very clearly have a person of course
there's a sense of entitlement there do
you guys know what happened to Sam
Britton or what his status is right now
is he arrested and he got arrested at
his home in Maryland most recently so
with the the bag stolen in Vegas there
were uh he was convicted he had to pay
uh fine in Minnesota a similar thing
brought up on charges there was a fine
but also he had to undergo mental health
uh evaluations as part of sort of a a
deal to to lessen the charges against
him I haven't gotten an update on what
happened with with the arrest in
Maryland which is connected to the DC
airport which presumably is this woman
in Houston unless there are more missing
bags that we don't know about he said he
fled he was a per he was a a fugitive
Justice that was the that was what he
was arrested under and I'm not sure I
see I'm surprised he had to undergo
mental health examination because I can
just take one look at him and see he's
clearly seen I mean yeah yeah I think
that's why they're like how could such a
sane healthy individual like you get
into stealing bags we just can't
understand so we actually in Britain
have had two recent scandals of married
men with children who have been on TV
stations for a very long time one was a
news reader the other one hosted a
daytime TV show
um they have claimed mental health
scares once they've been caught trying
to solicit photos or hook up with young
men of teenage questionable age wow yes
and uh one of them tried to get out
ahead of it about a year and a half ago
by saying that I am coming out as gay
and isn't this Brave and then it turns
out that he was having an affair turns
out with someone on the set so you have
to come out as as brave because yeah
otherwise you might think I'm a terrible
Creed yeah exactly and what they end up
doing is they Retreat into saying oh um
this is one it's homophobic to criticize
this and two I've been checked into the
hospital for a mental health emergency
so we're going to leave this story alone
for a while yeah you have to leave me
alone this is another important part of
it right I mean look it no one is like
making the argument that every single
person who struggles with any kind of uh
perversion is trying to attack children
but the reality is if you have they them
pronouns next to your name any predatory
behavior that you engage in is going to
be defended by the media and by the left
and anyone who points out that you're
doing something suspicious is going to
be labeled a bigot but it's at some
point you have to action speak for
themselves it that is the way of the
world that is if we want to survive as a
species you cannot be like well you hurt
all those people okay like no man if you
if you if something you didn't this goes
for leadership as well if something you
did causes maybe a surrender Afghanistan
and the death of children and and people
trying to flee the country being
beheaded like you're on the hook for
that you can't just be like oh I was 85
years old and I wasn't thinking about it
like they I I
I want some I want some responsibility
for these behaviors and this is I have
empathy for people with mental health
issues for sure but at some point
there's no you've got to be realistic
about it yeah I mean I I have compassion
for people who have mental health issues
I don't have like that much compassion
for the people who elect them I feel
badly in some sense for for Joe Biden
other than you know he put himself in
this situation to an extent it was very
huburistic I think there's an argument
to be made that because of his steeply
declined mental health that people and
his family probably bear a larger brunt
of the responsibility for this than we
could attribute to him though I don't
want to totally remove agency from him I
mean he he has his moments but to an
extent he seemed at least at the time
when he began running to still be
capable of making decisions I think the
people around him should have said don't
do this you know you're too old but of
course not I mean he's he's uh he's he's
a cash cow he may I you know call me
crazy he may even be the big guy that uh
Hunter was uh referring to yeah
it's crazy yeah he's gonna say you can't
blame all of us some of them are dead
yeah I mean look they uh they elected
him because he's an elderly guy they
could they they could relate
representation yeah matters I thought
yeah well this is I think that's
literally confirmed that did they
actually literally confirm that they
found some people hadn't been taken off
The Voice rules yes yeah and so suspect
well I I mean I think ultimately with
this story about Sam Burton so I'm gonna
I'm gonna go back to it is we know that
we should have compassion for people who
are struggling mentally or emotionally
right but that doesn't mean that we have
to excuse this Behavior right or elect
them or elect them or in this case uh
think that anything about what's
happening is normal and I think that's
one of the reasons that uh really I see
this story most reported by more
conservative leading Outlets because you
know it drives home all the points of
look at this bizarre person who clearly
does not respect any sort of traditional
or conservative values who who would
probably denounce them all and this is
one of the consequences in fact this is
a very seemingly mild consequence
because it doesn't really involve
violence right it's theft it's it's
terrible but on the other hand you know
there we have seen more uh more more uh
devastating devastating results from
people who are unstable in recent
history well yeah I think that this idea
that we're seeing a violation of trust
the idea that you would get to take your
own bag home from the airport should be
serve as evidence that perhaps if we
don't have a strong moral Foundation
that we all agree to and adhere by that
everything starts to fall apart totally
agree no I totally agree with you on
that and I'm sure we all agree on that
point and when you look at someone like
this particular character a lot of the
other people have been pointed appointed
to positions in government lately or
even elected
you kind of have to wonder how something
like that could possibly have happened
of course that's a rhetorical question
we all know about the cultural changes
that have occurred over the past several
decades and the pressure that the media
has put on average people but we've
rerouted our thinking towards saying it
is mean it is hurtful it is terrible and
it is unacceptable to ever Place someone
in an out group on the basis of the way
that they act the way that they choose
to dress here's the thing when you have
a representative democracy it's
important that political leaders
represent you who does he represent is
this someone who represents the average
person what are you talking about about
Biden well I think Biden's actually a
fairer question it's fair to ask that
question about him I would say sam in
particularly I don't think he wasn't
elected he was appointed
yes hence it's exactly and what he
represents are um degenerates who are
very easy to compromise yes and that's
the perverse incentive to appoint people
who are well outside the norm because
they have a stake in the regime
protecting them at all times and going
along with a very permissive Progressive
Orthodoxy man it's we I'm very concerned
with the levels of crime increases with
the economy inflation and stuff like I'm
not into authoritarian Crackdown in any
way but at some point well I shouldn't
say in any way like there have been
instances where countries have like
uprisings and they have to have some
sort of authoritarian Crackdown on the
uprising to preserve the country but I I
don't want that I don't want it to get
to that point it's it's like you should
be able to talk through this and like
encourage people to like stand up for
themselves and take their property
rights seriously that's very
compassionate yeah unfortunately not
everyone's as smart as as you there's
not meant to be condescending at all
some people only respond to incentives
and not ideas there are some people that
if given the system of permissions we'll
just go out and loot and burn and take
what they want and that's why nay
bakayley cracking down on El Salvador
you see the New York Times going oh this
is a liberal it's like yeah but we're
not going to get it wrong because they
have skull face tattoos we know who the
criminals are and then it turns out once
you crack down on the criminal element
your country improves yeah absolutely
and I'll mention this Ian you try to be
careful with that and I think maybe
you're putting too much uh pressure on
what you're supporting with the use of
this term authoritarian you're saying
well maybe we need authoritarian
crackdowns well who says a crackdown's
always authoritarian if people are
rioting in the streets and burning down
innocent people's businesses then
they're the authoritarians and Civil
Authorities are just stepping in to
promote the rights of the people who are
being harmed by uh the the rioters but
we're gonna head over to Super chats
right now so everybody please smash that
like button share this video become a
member at timcast.com so you can join us
in the after show at 10 10 where viewers
will be calling in live to talk with us
so we have uh from Waffle Sensei Tim if
you're listening blink twice if you're
in danger he may take your spoons he may
take your beanie but he will never take
your freedom firstly why would you be
asking him to Blink twice when you can't
even see him does he think I'm Tim is
the beanie working
why is he quoting a Scotsman in my
presence I'm almost offended that's a
fair point yeah it's almost a hate crime
it really was a sign Yeah
Tim is fine you know and sometimes
people just they just need to step away
for a little bit Tim just a quick break
Tim just tweeted out today he doesn't
like MRIs yeah he doesn't enjoy MRIs
twice t-bomb regenerate slowly my man we
have from Raymond g Stanley Jr shame as
well done last night cheers thank you uh
have you seen the first edition of Tim
cast Discord news you are the main story
it's pretty hilarious yes somebody did
send that to me and I didn't find it fun
yeah I think it's something I didn't
find that funny
I
I won't say anything I didn't find
anything it continued to level the same
insane I definitely didn't hear him
giggle when he saw it on Twitter today
that's definitely not Sheamus's Style
giggle first of all no noise that has
ever come out of my face could be
described as a giggle
I could not do it I've never done a
giggle in my life even when I laugh at
something it's a hearty man what if it's
a what if it's a hard G like jiggle no
no neither neither of those I don't
really think I jiggle all that much
either I don't have enough body fat I'm
just here to report what I heard I I
can't say it sounded like once again
more fake news from the media more fake
news from the liberal press uh Nate Pro
says hey Connor glad to see you here
thank you big fan of the lotus eaters
and as the most base person there you're
my favorite keep up the good work and
spread truth my guy at the base person
at the Lotus Eaters he obviously thinks
you're the most base person here so
that's funny because someone else today
uh uh at certain Roman rat on Twitter
um pseudonym of an academic named Nemo
paulvini uh he said my colleague Harry
was the most base person and I did get
my backup about that so so myself and
the northern monkey himself will be will
be dueling it out at your office instead
of having employee of the month do you
have like based person the month I mean
how does this work so there was there
was a Discord channel that used to exist
called uh Josh's based takes from which
I will not read out because I will not
incriminate my friend but I think Josh
might have had a monopoly on that for
quite a while dude how's Lotus Eaters
going by the way like do you guys have
any public plans coming up uh so we've
just moved to New Studios so that's
really cool we've just unveiled that
because beforehand the bit of behind the
scenes it was just one room and we had a
curtain separating our filming stuff so
as soon as we were recording the lights
would go off and every writer was in the
room had to be silent because it was all
open plan office now we've got two new
Studios one's a bit of a library one's
the five person round table it's really
cool
um we might do a third one we'll we'll
see what we we cobbled together and then
future expansion plans there might be
some stuff in the works but but now
we're just really glad that we get to
record more concurrent content more
hosts and I believe
um Stelios Carl and Beau did a
discussion the Epic of Gilgamesh which
was four hours the other day so that's
the kind of stuff we're gonna do going
forward is this what you saw
went into debt for your University
degree what did you see yourself doing I
wasn't really sure because I didn't
really get into politics until my second
year and what ended up happening was I
was finding myself arguing with all of
the other seminar participants about to
show up and the seminar leader when I
thought I was dating observable truths
and we actually had and I don't think
I've told this story before so okay this
should be fun uh fantastic exclusive
yeah yeah well I wouldn't incriminate
myself
um we had invited as part of student
Society with a lot of students for
Liberty chapter so very tepid very free
speech we'd invited my current boss Carl
Benjamin to speak and uh antifa the
feminist Society showed up in
coordination with the Student Union who
were elected at the time and this was
published in the student newspaper to
quote bait them into being abusive to
start fights to shut the society down
um my then girlfriend had her work cool
to try and get her fired they spray
painted and defaced the side of the
sports Stadium
um they made threats when we had an
Israeli and Palestinian Ambassador show
up with the first UK University to do
that and then they decided to get into
our group chat and fabricate screenshots
of edgy jokes to make us look really bad
wow and so we got sat in front of the
University tribunal Free Speech tribunal
where genuinely diversity inclusion
coordinator had had brought up quotes
from durstormer saying oh the Nazis use
humor to recruit their members so that's
what you guys been doing and the person
that was chairing that particular
tribunal
um was one of the student union members
that had tried to stop the fight on
campus so conflict of interest
completely overblown we got chewed out
for it so then after that um my friend
decided to set up a little Think Tank
thing trying to tell the UK government
that they're spending too much money on
Environmental Policy I joined that I
wrote a little bit on the side and then
I abandoned the government thinks they
barely listened to me they listened once
and then not the rest of it frustrating
and then just sort of went into
commentary and TV and whatnot
accidentally uh so yeah long story short
no didn't think I'd be here bit surreal
actually how'd you meet Carl
um so other than him coming to the
University campus um I went to uh
University with Callum and so Calum and
I've known each other for a few years uh
but I went to a low Caesar's live event
um and Carl had like a bit of an adverse
first impression of me but I started
telling stories and he was like oh
you're right actually you're not much of
a knob as I thought
um and then so I got invited as a as a
guest just to do a sort of guest podcast
it was meant to be with a former
employee but he wasn't showing up for
the day so so I ended up doing one with
Callum and then Carl just went to me oh
do you want to come and get a cup of tea
you have a chat and I was like yeah yeah
thanks for bringing the engagement so
when do you start
um so that was yeah that was really cool
nice yeah they didn't even have to
interview for it and I'm very thankful
what did you say you're like I start
next week or uh I was I was like well I
need to figure out uh how to get here
how to move here and and you know
um but yeah no I'm very enthusiastic and
the thing the lovely thing about lotuses
is that we have actually built parallel
institution where all of us are good
friends like though some of those guys
and I think you know I don't want to
sound soft but some of those guys I like
my brothers and they've got I've had
I've had a hit and Missy a
professionally great personally a bit
rough and they've been there for me so
I'm very thankful to call them all those
guys for putting that together that's
great man uh no it's good that he's
building something over there right he
decided move outside of just having a
brand based on his personality and
started welcoming other people he's got
four kids you know yeah he's a busy guy
yeah yeah yeah uh from CTI 29
this is actually really heartbreaking
um someone I know is 17 year old
daughter got an abortion today at 13
weeks I'm just asking for prayers for
the family I can tell it hurt them and
it seemed like they thought there was no
other option and so in a lot of these
situations a person feels like there's
no other option and that's why they do
it but there is always another option
there is always hope there is always a
way for that child to live
yeah and thrive
I think this is one of the things that
we should be most irritated and most
most infuriated about about modern
culture which is you'll get articles
from Teen Vogue that say this is how you
comfort your friend after she gets an
abortion it's obviously targeted to
young women in their 20s probably even
younger it's teen folk and they act like
there are no consequences to this
decision ultimately you're you're going
to be happy you did it because your life
is messed up by the results of of
decisions you made exactly and I think
that is
uh just horrific right it is it's
fear-mongering too for all the the time
they spend accusing the right of
fear-mongering the left fear-monger is
about human life if we have too many
people in the world it's gonna be
horrible everyone's gonna starve if you
have that child you'll never achieve
your dreams your life will be horrible
and then they accuse us of being
emotionally manipulative for wanting to
show people ultrasounds which literally
just show you a picture of what the
child whose life you're contemplating
ending looks like you tell me what's
more manipulative but that's telling
someone they're never going to be happy
if they have this child or showing them
the child that's how weak this argument
is though one that the image of one
sonogram could change everything for
someone that's why you can't see that
there's actual life uh that you're
terminating through an abortion you're
supposed to be completely separate from
it so think of it like getting a haircut
maybe going to the dentist something
innocuous which is completely misleading
right you should be fully informed about
the decisions you make of course a young
person a 17 year old can't fully
understand the consequences of all of
their actions on the other hand we can't
act like abortion is an emotionless uh
run-of-the-mill thing yeah so let's all
say some prayers for for that family
yeah we have from Matthew Hammond Connor
made it on timcast IRL before Carl
Benjamin look at that yes well it
coincided the general trip from mine and
thank you to Serge for for saying oh you
know this guy might not be terrible
um Nicole is just genuinely so busy like
I did say to him Marge you want to
conjoin our trips and come do stuff
because you know we had potential other
plans and other shows that were asking
and uh he just couldn't make it out this
time because it was too short notice
he's just had his fourth child she's
less than six months old
um yeah so he's building an empire both
at loads of Caesars and at home and uh
yeah so hopefully he will be able to
come over either later in the year or
early next year and you guys will get
the preferred candidate the full Mighty
I felt like this was great I wouldn't
swap you oh yeah I wouldn't swap you
talk about the spear we have uh from no
soup for nulls came for Tim dot dot dot
who the eff is this guy so for those of
you who don't know no soup for Knowles
is an unbelievably terrible woman who
does the voices for the female
characters in Freedom Tunes just you
know I I would have I'd fire her
instantly if I had any other option but
unfortunately women refuse to talk to
you when you're a cartoonist so yeah
it's uh it's it's an unfortunate reality
but uh she she likes doing the cartoon
she treats me very poorly it's really uh
Horrible no soup for Knowles yeah no
super Knowles that's so funny yeah yeah
I love that you're gonna Dodge this
question who is this guy you're like
just attacking the person who raised the
question she's listen she's
we have from Joe Mallett Ian Jiu Jitsu
do it started at 30 and wish I had
sooner heading to my class now I'm very
open to that Phil Labonte you know does
Jiu Jitsu a little bit I won't not you
know a little bit but he's actually been
having I think he said he had a knee
injury from it a month a few months ago
which is a pain in the ass so you know
one one step at a time but I'd have to
cut my hair I think I'm not comfortable
going in there and grappling with long
hair no you should wear like a bathing
cap dude no no wear like one of those
bathing caps you could be like corn pop
in there bro yeah you're like yeah
bathing cap maybe clay Guida is one of
was the great Grappler and he's always
had really long like wild caveman hair
it's just part of the aesthetic wild
okay when I roll back on my back it I
don't like it polling so I'd have to get
it up and and bound we just gotta teach
you a French braid your own hair I'm
telling you have you not seen women's
UFC that's that's the key all right I'm
into it you just got to do it you got to
braid your hair they'll lose their minds
they'll accuse you of like cultural
appropriation or something like that
every minute of that
oh my goodness
um we have here from agamemon's gym bag
it's a great name I'd bet North FC loves
Trump good to see you Connor one of the
best Lotus one of the best on the Lotus
Eaters oh thank you very much yeah he
actually super chatted in quite a while
ago plugging one of my segments to Tim
which was uh which was appreciated uh
yeah are you guys familiar with North FC
no okay so you're not like soy Jacks the
the like open mouth glasses guy that's
pointing it's like kind of that art
style
um I don't know if you'll be able to
pull up a photo of it as such but it's
like a big pogi man poorly crudely drawn
and he'll say very basic things that
like anyone with sense of agree with
it's like you know you know the
Theologian and the I think I've seen
this meme yeah yeah and he'll just be
like love me country love me why love
mcgreggs uh hit the global as simple as
and it's simple as the trustworthy
British pub man you'll find anywhere
that is the heart of the country yeah he
does enjoy Trump yes yeah yeah that's it
that's Buzz there he is what's his name
again
that's the gentlemen in question okay
yeah and it's a solid meme I've seen it
I've seen it a number of times I assumed
it was looks like a Mike Judge character
it actually does
like a Mike Judge character actually so
he's got a very trustworthy face I would
say so I think I trust the guy he's seen
things yeah is he gonna make an
appearance in Freedom Dunes uh I can't
just plagiarize somebody else's
character I mean you can except for for
Joe Biden he's one of the only funny SNL
characters to ever have been created
he's
I refuse to believe he's real
um I so we have from
saddle effing Trump I'm sorry um I
have to commend Sheamus as a potato
American Catholic being so simple with a
British Protestant uh original
Protestant that's insults
oh yeah you're Canadian I'm British
Canadian that's why I've never seen born
in America HC yeah my you'll be hearing
from my Priest No I'm uh I'm my Bishop I
am actually an Irish Catholic half of my
family from Donegal um if my if my mum
slash Nan hadn't have been married my
name would either be Connor James McDade
or Conor James Daly in his Irish on his
mom's side which means he's actually
Irish yeah exactly yeah were you born in
Ireland no no no my nan was and she had
the accent until she she moved over so
uh yes yeah we're good
um so are you your company's diversity
higher though
oh yeah technically the Irish aren't
white so it's me me and Callum are black
um that's what I've heard Josh is quite
swarthy Stelios is Greek so he's
technically black I guess I guess you
know here's the thing in the U.S the
Irish are considered white but the the
Irish were only considered white what's
being white meant you had to apologize
for being white so we really got in and
cut into the worst time at the worst
possible time to get on being white
um uh excuse me red rummix says m in UK
medical job had training today on how to
write gender-neutral reports so we
cannot say she or he
we are not allowed to use any pronouns
at all Madness that is because that's
going to be a great way to communicate
that's going to be super clear anecdotal
but that's concerning if that's true
that's how the NHS management staff all
run they the diversity uh inclusion
coordinators over there go for 7 CT or
80 000 pounds uh salary a year um the
NHS by the way just to smell like any
Romanticism about Universal Health Care
and how it normally plays out to an
American audience
um we have an exponential increasing
budget that can never meet demand and
the amount that we spend on bureaucracy
is hellish and so there's this trickle
up effect and like they spent they spent
like thousands of pounds painting
rainbow crosswalks outside of the of the
hospitals every year
it saves lives exactly how do they know
they're gonna they're gonna be safe at
that hospital the rainbow sidewalks I'm
convinced they're only there so that the
lefties can have their persecution
complex validated every single time
there's a skid mark on it like why would
you put your sacred symbolism on a also
how can you be the minority group if
we're painting your groups I feel like
this doesn't make sense it literally
makes no sense it literally makes it
makes no sense that's what I find so
exhausting is trying to like grapple
with the logic or there for lack of
logic from the other side because I do
feel obligated to sort of uh consider
where someone would be coming from but
at a certain point you have to just say
like you know you don't make sense right
yeah not because I mean it's just that
you don't make it exactly exactly
um essay federale says Conor England has
nothing in regards to Aristocrats they
wrote an entire joke called The
Aristocrats about the Biden family what
are your thoughts uh England does still
have somewhat of an aristocracy it's
just that they don't really consider our
concerns anymore this is this is kind of
the oh I'm gonna upset your show this is
kind of the Great lie of democracy it's
the it doesn't it doesn't really matter
whether or not every mechanism is based
on consent it matters whether or not the
the landowning Gentry is substantively
they see you as part of their moral
constituency yeah um like the American
aristocracy yeah sure they're elected
sort of I mean the gerrymandering and
all that
um but they consider the people they
rule over less than a feudal Lord would
have consideration for his peasants and
so and we still we still have an
aristocracy to an extent I mean the
House of Lords is still appointed as
periods by the Prime Minister and
they're very rich people on that and you
know they get final say on legislation
and whatnot um it's just that a lot of
the aristocracy are captured by
Progressive ideals so they don't even
have the all-class dynamic anymore yeah
no I think that's interesting and
there's definitely something to that one
thing I love which Hans Sherman Harper
said is that yeah is that uh part of
what democracy does is it eliminates
class Consciousness right so people who
are lower on the authority hierarchy
don't really see themselves as separate
from their leaders because they've
gotten to choose them like make no
mistake you are in separate classes you
are absolutely in separate classes and
and I agree with you that not every
mechanism like the the idea that every
mechanism within government being based
on consent is what makes it functional
is is absolutely nonsensical obviously
there are certain people who are
unappointed bureaucrats and I have issue
with that if you're in a nation which
Prides itself on being Democratic but uh
ultimately what's important is that we
have laws that help a man reach his
final end which help a man to to live
virtuously have a good life be able to
provide for his family the things that
actually matter to people uh and so I
I'm there with you think on this says as
a former University employee I say raid
the university endowments to pay off
student loans who do you think benefited
from lying to people about the positives
of one Higher Education and two taking
out loans okay so here's where I'm going
to disagree with you uh on this for as
much as I'm sympathetic to making the
colleges pay for this if you raid that
what you're essentially doing is taking
the money that people who have already
paid off their debt financed and then
giving it to people who haven't paid off
their debts if you're going to
redistribute the endowments if you're
going to redistribute the money that
these universities got it actually makes
more sense to redistribute that money to
college educated people who already paid
off their loans is there any University
in America that uh because a lot of
endowments are generated through
fundraising through alumni are there any
colleges in America that states their
alumni hey you could donate directly to
someone's student loan debt oh that's a
great idea set of scholarships why don't
we just say like you could give me ten
thousand dollars and we will actually
give it to the kid who's in ten thousand
dollars with the student loans
sponsorships essentially right I don't
understand why it's always you know I
understand the point of scholarships and
understand although I don't always agree
with why universities fundraise but if
we wanted to have a forgiveness program
wouldn't it be interesting to have you
know the alumni of a school say this
student has taken out loans they seem to
be performing well academically I want
to pay off their loan and the schools
why are we having this third party the
ones that have more repayments through
that kind of process would have more
people applying to them and there would
be an expectation that when you became
uh if you were an alumni in a position
where you're finding it was financially
viable you would then contribute in a
similar way and that system would be
really cool but instead we're like no no
give your money to the college to then I
think I don't know waste that's a great
idea that's a really good idea then
that's the thing even though as I
mentioned a person ends up making more
as a result of having a college
education I still think degrees are
massively overpriced and so the fact
that you'd pay more for something than
you should have and then they would ask
you for more money is totally wild just
the the audacity C.S Cooper says
Connor's so awesome right Stateside when
can we expect Lotus Eaters USA division
P.S tell Calum I said dot dot dot dot
um so C.S Cooper we have a video
comments for any of our paying members
um so if they pay us the gold tier which
is just 30 pounds a month um they can
send in a video comment at the end of
our podcast and interact with us and and
Craig who who pays his monthly
subscription and uses it very kindly to
promote his books uh we're building
culture I suppose
um but but yeah Legacy is USA division
uh we do not quite have the budget to
expand to that at this point though if
we are chased out the country I mean we
might just become de facto loads of
Seasons USA division so who knows well
just come join us in West Virginia
that'd be fun don't tempt me
um excuse me unbelievable Alan Shore
says clearly YouTube is holding Freedom
Tunes accountable for under house
dwelling people stealing spoons so this
is exactly the problem
this is exactly the problem with
spreading misinformation on the internet
there's no evidence I ever stole spoons
but there's Karma there's no evidence
that I'd live there is not and there's
also no evidence that I live under Tim's
house and steal his spoons this is
ridiculous but I think there's actually
credibility to this theory that I'm
being falsely punished for crimes that I
did not commit because Tim Poole this is
you know what I'm gonna have to talk to
The Daily Beast about this one last week
I saw Sheamus emerge from the basement
actually I didn't see you emerge I just
saw you from where the basement is from
that area and then I saw you walk over
to a berry bush and just pick some
berries and then eat them that actually
did happen and then he walked back hold
on hold on how did I eat them one hand
one finger at a time interesting so no
spoon was used eat the berries
do you think suffering through these
allegations will make you stronger I
think it will make me stronger as a
person yeah and that should scare all of
you yeah yeah so do you think you
actually benefit from this
misinformation it's a trial that you are
therefore benefiting from I think things
that happen to you are all things that
you can benefit from ultimately that
doesn't mean it's not an injustice and
it isn't Injustice should we release a
formal spoon count of how many spoons
are available on property and what that
compares to I mean I didn't never now
you want a nanny state to go around and
count everything I just feel like we
have to do it this is ridiculous we have
to do an in-depth study this is
ridiculous
down these paranoids
they call me
this is this is garbage this is nonsense
it's just been going on for too long I'm
just saying we can't say if the spoons
are missing if we don't know how many
spoons we have and Tim won't even come
back he's so angry
I'm joking by the way you guys geez
everyone was quiet no he left because he
he's stealing his stuff
he's not mad at you I don't blame him he
just needed to take a break go to the
farm hang out you know he'll come back
then we'll be back next week
everyone's like we'll see what's the
only reason the show's good it depends
if I if I if I allow Tim to come back
he'll be back but we're gonna have to
see about that
um Stefan vide or I'm sorry Veda what is
wrong with me
um unbelievable interesting number
Ukraine uses 5 000 artillery shells per
day U.S makes 80 000 per year Russia is
estimated to make 700 000 to 3.3 million
per year and Biden says we're low on
ammunition this isn't good
I gotta hear those numbers again
Ukraine uses five I feel like I'm
reading a word problem almost now uh you
pray I'm like you're crazy I'm with you
dude as soon as I read something like
what was the what were the numbers uh
Ukraine uses 5 000 artillery shells per
day the US makes 80 000 per year Russia
is estimated to make 700 000 to 3.3
million per year and Biden says we're
low on ammunition this isn't good
interesting
that isn't yes I agree Joe Biden talking
is not good I've never been a fan I I
know we haven't touched on Ukraine at
all and I know foreign policy expert but
my position on it is I'm a little
Englander and I don't want to pay for
either country that's just a radical
take I suppose but just completely
illogical how could you do this people
of Ukraine that's like uh calling
somebody it's weird we have this term
isolationist like it's it's anti-social
to not want to go to war with other
people it's like what I'm not saying we
can't trade with other people or be
friends with other people saying don't
go to war with them what
um what's what's more isolating being at
peace with other countries or going to
war with them you tell me
um blanks
b-l-e-n-cz says yes with an exclamation
point so let's yes my two favorite
Catholic political commentators are on
the same show question for Connor what
has been your favorite and least
favorite part about visiting the states
also when is the next Comics Corner
happening okay so Columbus common is
coming out I think tomorrow might be
depends on uh if our wonderful editor
Jack has been doing double time since
I've been away it's on the it's on the
history of comics part one we're gonna
have another berserk one coming out soon
as well it's very inside baseball guys
basically Carl pays us to talk about
Comics once a month like a job
um the so visiting the state uh I feel
like a Smurf because everything is
massive here like why do you have four
lane roads that would be a highway where
I'm from this is ridiculous but I can
tell that if the Revival is going to
come from somewhere it's definitely
going to come from here first and
because you guys still have a deep sense
of social texture even in deep blue
Massachusetts there was a two to one
ratio of national flags to Pride Flags
uh there is still latent Christianity
here I mean I'll paraphrase Nietzsche
who I don't like but he was right in the
if God is considered dead culturally
then the great cathedrals of Europe will
become the sepulchers and mausoleums to
a dead idea and that is largely what has
unfortunately happened with both the
hollowing out of the congregations in in
the UK and also like the Archbishop of
York coming out and saying the Lord's
Prayer is patriarchal and oppressive it
is patriarchal yes yes
I got news for you the universe is a
patriarchy we have a king like that's it
yeah that's well that's one way to look
at it no get out in your band yeah
you want the world view that posits that
I'm some kind of lunatic spoon Thief
then you you know we're going to do it
on the after show I think the comment on
the highway is the best one if you've
ever driven in England it's Americans
can't do it especially if you're in more
rural areas trying to go down any road
you'll see these cars speed towards each
other and just narrowly skate one
another it's terrifying that is that is
the only thing that I have experienced
I've had uh friends who have tried to
encourage me to move out here and and
this is the hitchin's position being
denethal you know flea Flee for your
lives England is lost and it's not that
I'm not sympathetic and I have come to
love this country quite a bit but I just
feel like I would I would be alien where
I try to call anywhere else home so for
for a little while I'll stay and fight
until I push down is it are the roads in
England are they just old is that why
they're smaller and they don't handle
cars yes we're not we're not a super
industrial town uh not Town country
country like you don't get like Ford
F-150 pickup trucks it's just completely
smaller scale or Freedom or toothbrushes
running like that is just like a
difficult contract all teeth are fine I
know it's like the number one
stereotypes right now listen I'll tell
you this much I gotta be honest with you
man when you're talking about the us
maybe having a Resurgence or being a
country that brings this stuff back I
hope you're right but it sounds like
it's really bad in in Europe if you can
be in a blue State and say you know
things are pretty good here that sucks
we we don't fly our national flag so
actually so this is what must have been
on the sound the Union Jack
um there are very few of them but each
country has its own national flag and
and the Scottish and Welsh and that
they're Celtic nationalist so they'll
fly there's England don't fly their
national flag and actually um I think
she was Shadow foreign secretary she
might now be the chief lawyer of the
labor party which is going to be the
incumbent government
um Emily Thornbury grotesque woman she
decided to tweet out a while ago a photo
of a council flat with a white van and
the English flag hanging outside the
window because it was a World Cup or
something and I don't know she
explicitly captioned it disgusting but I
remember that being the vipe and it's
the utter contempt the political
establishment have for patriotism in our
country it's near inescapable yeah yeah
that's a good point I I think a huge
part of that is if you're actually
patriotic to your country and you don't
blindly obey your political leaders
that's a problem for them actually
having you know faith and concern and
loyalty for and towards the values of
your nation rather than whatever
whatever political leader happens to be
in power or whatever movement is is
fashionable is absolutely you know I
have to eliminate I understand the
auditorism the the dislike of
nationalism sometimes because like we
could have a global system of
decentralized statehood like we could
just be a United States of Earth where
everyone governs themselves locally and
we're all connected through like you
know laws and internet regular but like
decentralized it could be more decent
like we don't have to stop here at
nationalism so Tech is a homogenizing
force that's the point it always has the
ratchet effect to Greater Global
surveillance cultural uh ubiquity
because it's easier to itemize and
that's that's why it stratifies people
into satising their individual desires
rather than having local parochial
geographically bound values so I I yeah
I am very skeptical of sort of the
possibility of international cooperation
to to keep together any sort of cultural
texture yeah yeah especially at that
scale uh well I I want to thank you all
for for watching thank you all for
stopping by uh and also everyone
watching if you enjoyed the show smash
that like button share the video uh and
Connor where can we find you uh where
you can find most of my work over at
lotuseeters.com you can find me on
Twitter At Con underscore Tomlinson
where I'll tweet out my articles for the
critic and my clips from from GP news
and one on please go and support all of
my colleagues work even if you don't
like me um the low seaters is a big cost
so there might be something for you over
on the website
that's awesome I'm so glad you were here
this is a great conversation I'm Hannah
Claire brimlow I'm a writer for
timcast.com you should go there click on
the read Tab and see all the work from
me from Chris Bertman from all of our
other journalists follow at timcast news
on Twitter and Instagram it's the bet I
can't I can't tell if you're gesturing
at me okay uh uh you can follow me
personally on Instagram and uh at
hannahclar.b and on Twitter at HC
brimlow thank you so much yes that was
Lively I loved it thank you Connor that
was awesome man good to meet you dude
yeah um you guys follow uh follow me on
in the internet at Ian Crossland this is
the name right behind me here and uh i n
c r o s s l a n d i I just think it was
where my ancestors crossed the land then
I was told like no that's where these
crucified people I'm like oh damn Is
that real are you notified to become a
fitness influencer yeah so what I'm
saying is I'm my my insurance fit
Brandon uh took video of me today
working out I have before pictures so
I'm going to be posting my journey
videos uh on I don't know Twitter I
think I'll focus them on Twitter I might
put them up on Instagram as well mines
as well so follow me on those platforms
and I'll be seeing you guys yeah again
thank you all for watching I'm Sheamus
Coughlin I have oh I'm so sorry Serge my
man it's cool man
I guess I love you and I'm sorry
it's all good dude uh thanks for joining
us Connor I I really wanted to have this
tap like to happen I I reached out to
Cassandra who does the booking it's not
me stop asking me I don't do anything
for the booking except in this case then
he intervenes yes I intervene because
you hit me I hit me up on Twitter and I
was like yeah if you're in town I'm sure
I can get you on the show here we are
Tim's not here but you know I can only
do so much not a miracle worker uh yeah
take it away Sheamus yeah uh so my name
is Seamus Coughlin I have a YouTube
channel called Freedom tunes that I used
to be able to get into uh we're hoping
that's going to be able to get sorted
out I'm optimistic it will because it's
it's clear we clearly didn't violate TOS
I think they're going to see it and
realize it was a mistake but just in
case something horrible happens or in
case something like this happens in the
future we have a website it's called
freedomtunes.com please go over there
all of our videos are there bookmark
that page if you're a fan of me because
even in this situation where I think
there was a mistake well
I'm not able to get in and upload video
so go over to freedomtunes.com bookmark
it and if you want to support what we're
doing uh please become a member you'll
get an extra cartoon every week that we
don't put on YouTube and that is
exclusive for members we're also going
to be starting to put behind the scenes
content up there thank you all so much
please go over to timcast.com and join
us for the after show at about 10 10
tonight